Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 104. Und ja, heute geht es mal wieder so um ein Thema, was hier schon ganz lange auf dem Tisch liegt. Und was so super schwammig ist, dass wir hier in der Vorbesprechung schon gut zwei Stunden verbraten haben, um überhaupt uns darüber klar zu werden, worüber wir eigentlich reden wollen. Abgesehen davon, dass wir natürlich in tausend verschiedene Nebendiskussionen uns auch dann noch verfangen haben über das Internet und das Leben und das Universum und den ganzen Rest. Und wir, das sind, ja, Daniel, Daniel Mack, hallo. Du warst ja auch schon hier. Wir haben uns ganz fleißig und sehr erfolgreich über USB unterhalten. War eine ganz gut nachgefragte Sendung, kann ich dir sagen.
Ist das so? Ist auch lange her, oder? Neun Monate, oder so?
Ist das schon so lange her?
Ich glaube, ja.
Wirklich? Oh Gott, wir müssen unbedingt mal wieder einen neuen Podcast machen. Wir sind dabei, so sieht es aus. Und zu meiner Rechten, Dirk, Dirk Jäckel.
Hallo.
Auch du bist das zweite Mal hier, stimmt es?
Das zweite Mal im Chaos Radio Express.
Letztes Mal haben wir uns über Java unterhalten, ganz ausführlich mit Boggle. War auch eine gut nachgefragte Sendung. Also, ich habe es hier mit gut nachgefragten Diskussionspartnern zu tun. Ich rede schon wieder dummes Zeug. Heute wollen wir uns, das liegt die Messlatte extrem hoch. Also jetzt ist es vorbei. Wir wollen uns heute einem Thema zuwenden, das einige Relevanz hat im Internet, nämlich E-Mail. Die elektronische Post, die uns alle täglich verfolgt, ist beeindruckt. Manche sind süchtig danach, andere sind überflutet mit Spam oder was weiß ich, was ihr alles so über E-Mail bekommt. Ich persönlich wäre zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt ganz gerne mal los gewesen, um ehrlich zu sein. Mich hat es einfach echt so genervt. Aber das waren dann auch immer diese Spam-Wellen, diese unglaublichen...
Ja, aber hält sich wacker, muss man echt sagen. Das stimmt. Das ist halt nach wie vor der wichtigste Dienst des Internets. Also sogar noch, laut Statistiken, noch vor dem WWW im Sinne von Webseiten und so.
Wie bewertet man denn da die Wichtigkeit?
Naja, auf was würdest du als erstes verzichten wollen?
Vermutlich das.
Wenn man dir die Dienste ein nach dem anderen abknipst.
Also für mich wäre E-Mail tatsächlich auch das Dramatische.
Aber so Webklicken finde ich irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, da kann man halt alles so abbilden.
Ja, aber wenn du Webklicken, ach du meinst, du könntest ja darüber auch Mail lesen, ja. Dann gäbe es auch keine Webmail. Keine Ausreden.
Ja, aber es gäbe Webseiten und man könnte Protokolle haben, sich Nachrichten zuzuschicken über Webseiten.
Naja, also E-Mail war so ein bisschen das Wunschthema von Daniel. Warum eigentlich?
Von mir?
Ja.
Was? Wirklich?
Du wolltest E-Mail machen.
Na, ich weiß nicht. Es gibt halt ziemlich viel darüber zu berichten und nicht alle Leute wissen irgendwie alles darüber. Manche wahrscheinlich vieles, aber ja. Deswegen dachte ich, man könnte vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen was darüber erzählen.
Und wann bist du das erste Mal mit E-Mail auf technischer Ebene zusammengestoßen?
Ach, das war gar nicht so diese fürchterlich frühen Phasen gewesen. Ich glaube, das war irgendwann 95 oder so. Also dann auch schon tatsächlich mit SMTP und POP und so. Ich habe dieses Ganze, was es davor noch gab, FidoNet und so habe ich mir komplett... Ja, das sowieso. Aber das habe ich alles nicht mitbekommen.
Also ich weiß nicht mehr, in welchem Jahr das bei mir war, aber es war Suborg, die Domain, bei der ich eine Adresse, oder einen Rechnernamen hatte und damit auch einen eigenen Mailserver und das war UUCP. Genau, Suborg, Subnetz und es hat drei Tage gedauert, von einem Uni-Account mir eine E-Mail zu schicken, weil da zwischen drei Hops waren und jeder nur einmal am Tag UUCP gepollt hat und das war ganz schlimm. Und dann habe ich in Berlin ausprobiert und da hatte ich Zugang zu jemandem, der direkt eine ISD-Einstandleitung hatte und da sind die Mails dann immer am selben Tag gekommen. Also auch noch UUCP, aber war schon schneller. Das war so mein erstes E-Mail-technisch Erlebnis.
Ja, das muss man gleich mal betonen. Es gab also mal eine Zeit, wo E-Mail durchaus noch in der Konkurrenz mit Snail-Mail war. Also wo irgendwie ein Stück Papier vielleicht dann doch schneller zum Adressaten geschafft hat als eben die elektronischen Daten. Das kann man sich heute gar nicht mehr vorstellen. Ja, jetzt sind ein paar Stichworte schon gefallen. Also womit ich ganz gerne mal einsteigen wollte ist Verständnis schaffen. Also das E-Mail-System nehmen die meisten Leute ja über ihren E-Mail-Client wahr. Sehr viele wahrscheinlich eben auch schon in Form eines Web-Browzers. E-Mail, Yahoo, das ist alles sehr populär. Hotmail, ganz klar. Aber was uns eigentlich jetzt mehr interessieren sollte, ist die eigentliche Architektur. Die hat sich ja auch entwickelt. Also man muss auch sagen, damals, was du jetzt noch erwähnt hast, das Usenet. E-Mail gab es sozusagen schon, bevor wir dieses vollvernetzte Internet in der Form weltweit hatten. Dienst hat sich einfach davon unabhängig entwickelt.
Ohne Standleitung, Store and Forward, Unix-to-Unix-Copy.
War halt darauf ausgelegt, vor allem eben für den Offline-Betrieb, beim nächsten Verbindungsaufbau eben.
Werden E-Mails übertragen, vorher noch gepackt.
Genau, da konnte so jede Applikation, die so Daten weiterzuleiten hatte, das irgendwo so in eine Queue schmeißen und dann wurde das alles in einem Shitload übertragen. Also auch News und so. Das heißt, Mail ging zunächst einmal auch davon aus, so zu sagen, so store and forward zu sein. Und in gewisser Hinsicht ist das ja auch immer so. Das heißt, Mail erreicht nicht, also könnte vielleicht unter Umständen, aber normalerweise erreicht eine Mail einen nicht direkt, sondern über Umwege. Und das können wenige Umwege sein oder eben manchmal auch ein paar mehr. Früher waren es halt in der Regel mehr. Jetzt sind es, ja, weiß ich gar nicht, wie viele sind es denn jetzt normalerweise? Zwei?
Na, also es ist auf jeden Fall immer der sogenannte Mail-User-Agent. Das ist das, was man so klassischerweise als Mail-Programm auf seinem Rechner kennt in der Kette. Und das hat eben jeder. Also jeder schreibt seine E-Mail in einem Mail-User-Agent und jeder empfängt seine E-Mail auch über den Mail-User-Agent. Und diese beiden können schon mal nicht miteinander kommunizieren. Somit braucht man auf jeden Fall mindestens einen weiteren Rechner in dieser Kette, der sogenannte Mail-Transfer-Agent, also der MTA, der Mails entgegennimmt und weiterleitet. Das heißt, man braucht mindestens erstmal ein Mail-User-Agent, ein MTA und nochmal ein Mail-User-Agent.
Das heißt, ist der...
Ist so still geworden.
Ich überleg gerade.
Als würde ich euch neue Dinge erzählen.
Ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt nicht so ganz so sicher. Ist alles, was zwischen Mail-User-Agents klebt, ein MTA?
Nein. Beim Absenden der Mail verbindet man sich mit einem Mail-Transfer-Agent, aber ein IMAP-Server ist kein MTA, oder?
Nein.
Das Abholen geschieht über einen anderen Server.
Das würde ich wohl meinen, weil die Mail landet ja am Ende irgendwo, wo sie gespeichert wird, bevor sie dann final zum User kommt.
Da gibt es noch einen sogenannten Mail-Delivery-Agent.
So heißt der.
Das möchte ich mir fangen.
Der dann eben klassischerweise POP oder IMAP spricht. Und das eben auch in verschlüsselten Varianten. Da kommen wir später nochmal zu Verschlüsselungen.
Und DNS ist auch noch im Spiel.
Das ist ja jetzt erstmal so das Big Picture. Wir haben sozusagen die Mail-Clients. Ihr kennt ja jeder, Thunderbird, eingebaute Mail-Programme.
Und in der Regel haben die einen fest eingebauten Mail-Server, dem sie ihre Mail alles schicken. Egal für wen es ist, schicken sie alles an einen SMTP-Server. Und dieser SMTP-Server guckt dann, wie er das weiterleitet.
Jetzt hast du gleich zwei neue Begriffe für dasselbe eingeführt. Mail-Server und SMTP-Server. Das ist das, was wir mit MTA bezeichnen. Vielleicht sollten wir erstmal ein bisschen Begriffshygiene schaffen. MTA ist ein Programm, was einfach nur dafür gedacht ist, Mail anzunehmen, damit es versendet wird. Und kümmert sich dann auch um das Versenden.
Genau. Und MTAs reden auch nur einmal mit dem Client, um die Mail anzunehmen. Aber dann reden sie nur noch mit anderen MTAs, um die Mail weiterzuleiten.
So lange, bis...
Bis einer sagt, die ist ja für mich. Und sie abspeichert. Und dann greift in der Regel der Mail-Delivery-Agent darauf zu, um sie dann dem User auf der anderen Seite...
Genau, wobei im aller einfachsten Fall, wenn der User, an den ich eine Mail verschicke, auf demselben Server einen Account hat, wie den, den ich verwende, um meine Mail abzuliefern, dann ist da im Zweifel eben ein Mail-User-Agent im Spiel, ein Mail-Transfer-Agent, der die Mail entgegennimmt und sie direkt wieder an einen Mail-Delivery-Agent weiterleitet, der sie dann wiederum ausliefert an den Benutzer, für den die Mail gedacht war. Das ist der allereinfachste Fall.
Kann aber auch sein, dass dieser MTA, andere MTAs, erst mal bemühen muss.
Das ist sogar sehr wahrscheinlich.
Warum ist das wahrscheinlich?
Na, weil ich in der Regel mehr E-Mails an User verschicke, die nicht auf meinem Server E-Mail-Accounts haben, als im umgekehrten Fall.
Bei T-Online-Usern könnte das anders sein.
Ja, das ist richtig. Aber selbst bei Google oder so. Das ist richtig, ja, natürlich.
Also wenn die Zieladresse nicht in der Domain meines eigenen Servers liegt, dann muss mein MTAs an einen anderen MTA weiterleiten. Genau, so kann man das, glaube ich, auch sagen.
Ja gut, okay, ja, stimmt. Das heißt, man hat irgendwie einmal MUA, zweimal MTA und dann noch einmal MDA oder auch nicht und dann noch einmal MUA und dann ist irgendwie die Mail da. Kann aber auch noch viele andere MTAs tatsächlich schon sein.
Richtig, ja. Der Vollständigkeit habe, sollte man an der Stelle vielleicht noch kurz sagen, dass das SMTP nicht zwingendeweise das einzige Protokoll ist, über das E-Mail im Allgemeinen so abgefrühstückt wird. Es gibt dann auch dieses X400. Allerdings habe ich das noch nie selber verwendet und mir ist auch nicht klar, wer das noch verwendet. Insofern kann man das einfach irgendwie ignorieren, glaube ich.
Ich glaube, das können wir wirklich ignorieren.
Ich habe vor zehn Jahren mal Adressen gesehen, die sehr kryptisch aussehen und X400-Adressen waren.
Wir reden jetzt hier über das Internet.
Das ist auch Internet, so ist es nicht. Aber SMTP ist eben deutlich weiterverbreitet.
Bedingt, bedingt, bedingt. Jetzt haben wir sozusagen zweite Begriffsebene erreicht. Wir wissen also jetzt, was es gibt. Warum machen wir das jetzt hier so mit dem Stock im Arsch? Weil man hier sehr schnell durcheinander kommen kann in dieser ganzen Diskussion mit wem was an wen schickt. Das heißt, SMTP ist das Protokoll, was mein Mail-Programm spricht, um seine Mail loszuwerden an einen MTA, der es sozusagen weiterleitet. Das ist so das Äquivalent zu, ich gehe zur Post und drücke dem Post-Mitarbeiter mein Paket in die Hand.
Interessanterweise ist das Protokoll zwischen dem MTA und dem nächsten MTA genau dasselbe. Das wäre so, als wenn der Post-Mitarbeiter zu einem anderen Post-Mitarbeiter geht und dem das Paket dann in die Hand drückt.
Nachdem man sich da schön in die Schlange gestellt hat.
Also das ist schon ein Unterschied zur Post, dass eben da dasselbe Protokoll gesprochen wird zwischen den MTAs und auch vom...
Wer jetzt mal seinen Mail-Client schon selber konfiguriert hat, der wird sicherlich bemerkt haben, dass man wirklich einen Shitload an Konfigurations-Items vorfindet, von denen eigentlich in den seltensten Fällen wirklich klar ist, was sie tatsächlich tun. Die erste Frage ist ja zum Beispiel dieser erste MTA, der normalerweise dann so was weiß ich, Outgoing-Mail-Server heißt oder sowas. Also der, den ich eigentlich immer benutze, den ich ja fest einstelle und der in der Regel zu den Mail-Accounts irgendwie dazugehört. Also wodurch ist festgelegt, wer das ist?
Na das ist in der Regel dein Provider, bei dem du eben deinen Zugang hast oder der Provider deines E-Mail-Accounts. Ob du das jetzt bei deinem Internetprovider dazubekommen hast oder ob das Google ist oder dein Firmen-Account.
Das ist irgendeiner, der deine Mail abnimmt. Und zwar tut er das, weil du dich in der Regel mit Usernamen und Passwort autentifizierst.
Aber theoretisch könnte man ja, wenn alle MTAs gleich sind, auch gleich mit dem MTA reden.
Du kannst gleich mit dem Ziel-MTA reden. Und der müsstest du dich auch nicht mal autentifizieren, um die Ziel-E-Mail abzusetzen. Aber dann müsstest du für jede Domain in deinem Mua, in deinem Mail-User-Agent, einen eigenen MTA eintragen. Das könnte man sogar machen.
Das ginge, ja, das ist richtig.
Weil in der Regel ist es so, man muss sich nur dann autentifizieren gegenüber dem MTA, wenn man woanders was hinschicken will, was nicht für diesen MTA ist.
Das nennt sich dann ein Relay-Host. Also wenn ein MTA, ein Mailserver, Mail entgegennimmt, die von dir kommt und irgendwo anders hingeschickt werden soll, dann musst du dafür eine Berechtigung haben. Also kannst du nicht jedem Mailserver auf dieser Welt deine E-Mail übergeben und sag, mach mal. Es gibt solche, da geht das. Aber dann spricht man von einem sogenannten Open Relay und die sind nicht so gern gesehen wegen der Spam-Verbreitung. Ist klar, wenn ich irgendwo E-Mails abladen kann und Tausende davon, die dann auch schon brav verschickt werden, dann ist das halt ein Problem für die Infrastruktur. Deswegen muss es eine Möglichkeit geben, sich zu identifizieren und dem Mail-Server zu erzählen, dass man das auch darf. Die Mail geht zwar woanders hin, die geht nicht direkt an dich, du bist dafür verantwortlich, diese Mail bitte weiterzuleiten, aber dazu braucht man eine Berechtigung. Und da gibt es eben verschiedene Möglichkeiten. Einmal eben SMTP-Auth, genau.
Bevor wir da vielleicht, ich würde das ganz gerne nochmal in dem Walkthrough machen. Ich wollte jetzt eigentlich nur mal feststellen, man verschickt erstmal mit SMTP, man verschickt an MTAs. Und in der Regel hat man einen Default-MTA, an den man erstmal alles verschickt und der verschickt dann weiter. Auf der anderen Seite, wenn die Mail ankommt, muss es ja auch wieder zum Mail-User-Agent, also zu meinem Mail-Programm irgendwie zurück. Und da gibt es aber ein anderes Protokoll. Also das wird nicht mit SMTP gemacht, sondern auf der anderen Seite liest man seine Mail auf verschiedene Art und Weise. Früher hat man halt seine Mail auch direkt auf den Computern gelesen, wo sie wirklich waren. Das ist nun wirklich Vergangenheit. Ich meine, manche Leute machen das noch, aber wer hat schon so seinen eigenen Server? Das ist eher so die Ausnahme. Und das ist jetzt auch nicht unbedingt gerade die Zielgruppe, die wir ansprechen wollen hier, sondern wir wollen einfach nur mal ein bisschen klar machen, wie das Mail-System funktioniert. Das heißt, das hast du ja auch schon erwähnt, es gibt POP als das ältere der Protokolle und der einfacheren der Protokolle und es gibt IMAP. Worin unterscheiden sich POP und IMAP und wann will man was haben?
Gibt es überhaupt einen Fall, wo man POP haben will? Also POP3 ist halt so, man meldet sich da an bei dem Server und sagt, gib mir mal die Mails und dann kriegt man alle neun oder alle, je nachdem. Und in der Regel löscht man sie dann auch dort, damit es nicht beim nächsten Mal länger dort wieder alles abzuholen. Weil, so werd ich mich erinnern, muss man immer alle abholen, die da sind. Und deshalb löscht man die in der Regel und dann sind die nicht mehr da und dann hat man sie nur noch auf seinem Notebook.
Nee, man muss die nicht löschen.
Nee, man muss die nicht löschen. Aber sie sind dann nicht als gelesen markiert, zum Beispiel.
Doch, es gibt so eine Möglichkeit, dass man tatsächlich nur die, die man beim letzten Mal nicht bekommen hat, dieses Mal dann abholt und so.
Ja, ja, aber wenn ich von einem anderen Rechner dann per POP3 meine Mails auch dort abhole, dann sind die nicht als gelesen markiert. Das ist nämlich zum Beispiel ein Feature von IMAP, dass die Mails als gelesen markiert sind. Und man lässt sie in der Regel auch auf dem Server, wenn man IMAP benutzt, damit man nämlich von verschiedenen Clients aus auf diese Mail zugreifen kann. Also nicht nur vom Notebook aus, sondern vielleicht auch noch von der Arbeit oder von zu Hause oder von irgendwo mit diversen, verschiedenen Rechnern. Und dann ist auch der gelesen Status immer der richtige, nämlich wenn man sie gelesen hat, ist sie halt als gelesen markiert und wenn nicht, dann nicht und das halt global und nicht nur in einem Client.
Also man kann festhalten, POP ist eigentlich aus der Zeit, wo man seine Mails abgeholt hat, wirklich, also dann wirklich sozusagen auch noch einen letzten Schritt gemacht hat. Das heißt, die Mails werden erstmal vorgehalten und sie kommen dann auf meinen Computer und dann sind sie dann bei diesem Server, der sie für mich vorgehalten hat, eigentlich weg. Man kann zwar schon irgendwie, ja, ich belasse die da noch, aber dafür ist das Protokoll nicht gemacht. Das Protokoll ist eigentlich gedacht, dass man es wirklich komplett abholt. Deswegen heißt es ja auch Post Office-Protokoll. Es ist so, als würde man da hingeht und seine Post holt.
Und noch ein Feature von einem IMAP ist dadurch, dass sie auf dem Server liegt, kann man auch auf dem Server suchen. Das heißt, der Client schickt nur noch an den Server, die Anfrage zu suchen und dann sucht der Server für einen und schickt einem dann eine Liste der Mails, die halt auf die Kriterien passen und man muss nicht mal alle abholen. Und es gibt noch diverse Features. Es gibt Folder, sowas gibt es bei POP3 auch nicht, oder? Also ich kenne POP3 einfach nicht mehr, das ist jetzt bestimmt zehn Jahre her, dass ich das benutzt habe. Es gibt Folder, es gibt öffentliche Folder in IMAP. Man kann also in einer Firma zum Beispiel, wenn nicht alle Mitarbeiter alle Mailinglisten lesen sollen, dann gibt es Folder, in die kann man reingucken oder auch Archive von Mailinglisten und so. Also IMAP hat halt einen Haufen praktische...
Also man kann festhalten, POP ist das Protokoll, um einfach Mails auf den Computer zu holen und dann hat man sie da und das ist dann der Ort, wo man sie dann später verliert und nie wieder sieht.
Genau, Backup ist natürlich das nächste Thema.
Und IMAP, nur um es nochmal zusammenzufassen, IMAP ist eigentlich dafür gemacht, dass die Mail auf diesem letzten oder vorletzten Schritt eigentlich verbleibt und man den Mail-Klein eigentlich nur noch benutzt, um da rein zu schauen und sie auf diesem Server zu lesen. Man kann sich zwar eine lokale Kopie machen, aber aus vielen Gründen behält man es eben vor Ort. Erster Vorteil ist, man kann mit mehreren Clients gleichzeitig machen, was weiß ich, man hat einen Webinterface, mit dem man irgendwie seine Mail liest, man hat eben seinen voll lokal, auf dem eigenen Rechner, voller Performance laufenden Mail-Klein und vielleicht hat man irgendwo noch einen zweiten Rechner, auf dem man das auch hat. Und was du eben vorhin meintest, mit gelesen, nicht gelesen markiert, also IMAP erlaubt es, einen State sozusagen mitzuspeichern. Das heißt, man hat nicht nur die Mail als solche, sondern man hat auch noch diverse Metadaten, man kann das irgendwie flaggen in dem einen Klein, und dann ist es in dem anderen auch gedeckt. Ich denke, das ist so im Wesentlichen der Scope, den sich da... Aber dieses Suchen, also IMAP bietet selber die Möglichkeit, zu suchen über das Protokoll. Das heißt, mein Mail-Klein kann dem Server sagen, suche doch mal danach, und dann kriege ich eine Liste von Mails, auf die das zutrifft. Benutzt das überhaupt jemand?
Ich glaube, mein Klein benutzt das, glaube ich. Bin mir nicht...
Bin mir auch nicht 100% sicher, weil im Zweifel geht das natürlich auch genau. Und wenn man über den Cash sucht, ist es im Zweifel genauso schnell.
Ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob Exchange das überhaupt unterstützt, zu suchen, oder Dovecat unterstützt, das glaube ich sogar ziemlich sicher.
Was ist im Dovecat?
Ein IMAP-Server. Ein ziemlich beliebter IMAP-Server sogar.
Es gibt halt diverse Implementierungen.
Also mein Lieblings-IMAP-Server. Wirklich?
Das ist für mich was Neues, weil ich kenne eigentlich nur, vielleicht kommen wir mal, es gab Kurier, der funktionierte für mich nie. Dann gab es Cyrus. Das ist eigentlich so auch der, wo IMAP herkommt. Cyrus, also C-Y-R-O-S. Das ist so die Jungs, die das auch mal entwickelt haben. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, war das ein Uni-Projekt oder so? Ich glaube, das war es. Wo halt einfach genau dieser Darf da war. Man will halt die Mail auf dem Server lesen und so weiter. Von daher war das eben auch lange Zeit die solideste Implementierung. Was hast du hier? Dove?
Wie die Taube? D-O-V-E? C-O-T.
Was ist C-O-T?
Der spricht auch IMAP-S. Also alles, was man sich so wünscht. U-IDLE kann der, glaube ich, auch.
Das ist auch ein ganz schönes Feature. Dieses U-IDLE. Dieses POP3 und eigentlich auch das IMAP basiert in der Regel ja auf so einem Polling. Das ist eine Polling-Idee. Genau, er ruft halt irgendwie ständig an. So einstellbar, im Mail klein. Guck doch mal alle fünf Minuten bitte nach meiner E-Mail, ob da was Neues dazugekommen ist. Und das natürlich an sich kein schöner Ansatz. Weil es irgendwie halt nicht immer irgendwas zu berichten gibt und man im Zweifel halt auch wirklich fünf Minuten warten muss, bis man E-Mail wirklich in seinem Postfach findet. Und deswegen gibt es diesen Idle-Mechanismus. Da setzt man eine Connection zu seinem IMAP-Server einfach auf Idle und sagt irgendwie, ich mache jetzt erstmal nichts mehr. Und der Server meldet sich auf diese offengehaltenen TCP-Verbindung zurück, sobald er E-Mail gesehen hat. Was ganz schön ist, weil dann kommt...
Ins Push-E-Mail. Das ist es, ne?
Also ist eine Implementierung von...
Das ist sozusagen der Briefträger kommt vorbei und macht vorne das Fähnchen hoch an der amerikanischen Briefkastenbox, die wir eigentlich haben.
Na, er klingelt eigentlich schon in der Tür. So, dass man es hört.
Du hast E-Mail.
Also um nochmal auch einen Nachteil anzusprechen von IMAP ist natürlich schon auch so... Also wenn man zum Beispiel gesendete Nachrichten speichern möchte, gibt es klassischerweise diesen FCC-Folder, wo dann eben File Carbon Copy, wo man E-Mails dann wiederfindet, die man selber verschickt hat. Egal, der liegt im Zweifel auch...
So was wie Send-Mail, meinst du jetzt?
Ja, ja, genau. Und die gesendeten E-Mails und auch die Drafts, genau, kann man eben in einen IMAP-Folder legen und das ist eigentlich auch ganz praktisch, weil wenn man von zwei Computern aus arbeitet, dann kann man eben auch auf dem anderen Computer in der gesendeten, in der Mailbox gesendete Nachrichten eben seine alten E-Mails noch finden, die man geschrieben hat. Das Problem ist, nur die müssen ja auch irgendwie hinkommen. Und bei IMAP funktioniert das so, dass der Mail-User-Agent zunächst mal mit dem SMTP-Server spricht und dort seine Mail abwirft. Und hinterher...
Das geht auch anders inzwischen.
Geht das anders?
Man kann es über IMAP direkt dort ablegen, in dem Send oder Draft. Also z.B. Thunderbird macht das auf jeden Fall so. Ja, das ist richtig.
Du musstest dann noch mal schicken. Darauf wollte ich raus. Also du musstest...
Du musstest noch mal schicken?
Na ja klar, du musstest einmal über deinen SMTP-Server schicken und einmal noch mal über deinen IMAP-Server.
Also das ist das, was ich beobachtet habe, wenn ich meine, das Verhalten meines Mail-Clients richtig hinterpläziert hat.
Ich bin ziemlich sicher, dass mein Mail-Client das über IMAP abspeichert und ich bin mir auch ziemlich sicher, dass es geht über IMAP. Und wenn ich es dann verschicken will, dann holt das sich halt wieder runter vom Server, dann bearbeite ich es und dann kann ich es über SMTP wegschicken. Was mich dabei stört, ist, dass die sich scheinbar alle nicht einig sind darüber, wo jetzt der Send-Folder und wo der Drafts-Folder ist. Ich habe nämlich drei Send- und drei Drafts-Folder pro Account und muss dann immer gucken, in welchem der drei Folder das jetzt drin ist. Aber ich glaube, ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass das über IMAP geht.
Ich denke, es ist sinnvoll, sich mal ein bisschen auf IMAP zu konzentrieren, weil wir schon richtig festgestellt haben, eigentlich gibt es nur noch zwei Arten von Usern. Die einen benutzen IMAP und die anderen benutzen Webmail. Wobei viele davon wahrscheinlich auch schon IMAP benutzen. Die einzige Firma, die zwar IMAP macht, aber irgendwie nicht IMAP macht, die ich jetzt so kenne, von diesen Webanbietern, ist allerdings Gmail. Also Google macht da irgendwas total Komisches. Ich habe das auch noch nicht so ganz verstanden, aber im Kern ist es so, Google hat ja dieses Modell des Labels. Das heißt, eine Mail kann mehreren Labels angehören, sie haben keine Folder. Normalerweise macht IMAP das eben so, man hat da so einen Ordner und die Mail ist halt entweder in dem einen oder in dem anderen. Aber eine Mail ist nicht an zwei Orten. Und jetzt macht Google das halt anders, weil sie da irgendwie quasi so ein Tagging damit machen. Diese Mail ist sowohl das als auch das, was ja an sich schon mal eine ganz interessante Sache ist, plus darüber bilden sie dann wiederum doch dann über Folder ab, was dann diesen komischen Effekt hat, dass dann halt wirklich eine Mail in mehreren Foldern ist, was man natürlich so nicht erwartet.
Ist sie denn in allen gelesen, wenn man sie in einem gelesen hat?
Das kann...
Weil dann wäre es mir ja egal, solange der Status immer der selbe ist. Ja, gut. Dann kann man sich das vorstellen, dass es nicht ein Folder ist, sondern wie ein View auf einen Datenbank- Abfrage, wobei die Datenbank-Abfrage in dem Fall heißt, zeig mir alles, was so getaggt ist.
Ja, es gibt da aber so widrige Sachen. Zum Beispiel gibt es da einen Folder, der da auftaucht, wo irgendwie all messages...
Stimmt, da sind dann verdammt viele Nachrichten, die der Kleine plötzlich runterholt.
Genau, da tauchen einfach so Sachen. Ich verstehe es auch einfach nur begrenzt. Ich habe einfach nur festgestellt, dass dieses Abbilden von Google-Mails internen Modell auf IMAP... Na ja, ich habe Sachen schon besser funktionieren sehen. Und ich frage mich jetzt vor allem eins. Es gibt doch dieses Feature auch in IMAP, dass man so eine Mail taggen kann. Dass man da wirklich auch so ein Label, so eine Metadata mit dran packen kann. Flagging ist sozusagen die einfachste Form davon.
Ist das begrenzt auf 10 oder so? Oder brauchen nur die kleinen 10? Ich weiß doch nicht, ob es eine Zahl ist, die daran gehängt wird oder eine geflagged. Weil du kannst ja mehrere Tags auch haben bei Gmail. Ich weiß nicht, ob das geht in IMAP.
Fragezeichen?
Ehrlich gesagt, ja. Also, ja. Ich habe das Feature-Sub-Init noch nie verwendet.
Ja, also ich benutze es auch nur, um mailsrot zu machen, damit ich...
Ich meine, jetzt kommen wir ja sozusagen auch ins Praktische rein. Weil zu verstehen, wie das Internet funktioniert, ist immer das eine. Aber man will ja auch E-Mail... Also, was ich immer total vermisst habe, ist einfach eben genau diese Möglichkeit. Mit diesem Flagging, sozusagen. Ich will sagen, diese Mail gehört zu Projekten sowieso, aber sie ist auch trotzdem irgendwie privat oder geschäftlich. Oder sie gehört sowohl in das eine Projekt, als auch in das andere Projekt rein. Dass man sie immer irgendwie nicht so richtig... Was ja eigentlich für jede Datei gilt, auf dem eigenen Computer.
Ja, also ich meine, da gibt es natürlich viele Möglichkeiten in den jeweiligen Mail-Klines dann wiederum mit so Smart-Mailboxes und so weiter. Wo man dann sagt irgendwie, ich habe hier eine virtuelle Mailbox. Da kommen automatisch alle Mails rein, die irgendwie von einer bestimmten Person kamen. Oder von einer anderen Person kam, eine Liste machen kann. Und da kann man auf diese Smart-Mailbox klicken und dann eben genau diese Meldungen aus seinem gesamten IMAP-Bestand zu sehen, die eben diese Kriterien erfüllen.
Ja gut, aber ich kann diese Kriterien nicht selber setzen, weil in dem Moment, wo ich die Mail bekomme, dann sind ja sozusagen alle Kriterien, auf die diese Smart-Mailbox zugreifen kann, sind ja schon gesetzt. Aber ich will ja in dem Moment, wo ich die Mail durchgelesen habe und sage, ah, das gehört zu dem Projekt, das gehört zu dem Projekt, das will ich dann sagen. Und dann müsste ja sozusagen diese Smart-Mailbox greifen.
Ja, also es gibt Mail-User-Agents, die eben genau diese Tags hier auch vergeben können. Und ich weiß nicht genau, ob das dann...
Aber dann bleibt das ja lokal in meinem Mail-Kline. Und nicht eben auf diesem Server. Stimmt, die Flaks sind auf dem Server.
Und die Tags in Thunderbird sind tatsächlich lokal. Aber Flaks können übernommen werden. Du hast dann halt nur ein Flag.
Also es gibt in IMAP nur eins, oder was?
Also ich weiß jedenfalls, dass ich Flaks auf verschiedenen Clients gesehen habe, die auf denselben Account zugegriffen haben.
Ja, das auf jeden Fall. Also für dieses einfache, ich setze eine Flagge. Ja, bloß damit sagt man ja wenig aus. Also ich hätte da mehrere Flaks, die ich gerne setzen würde. Ich habe dieses Flagge mit, das ist eine wichtige Nachricht, die ich später nicht löschen möchte. Und das ist eine Nachricht, die möchte ich mir in zwei Wochen nochmal anschauen. Und da würde ich schon ganz gerne mal unterscheiden. Aber das scheint ja nicht möglich zu sein.
Ein Feature von IMAP ist, dass es erweiterbar ist. Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es entweder schon diese Erweiterung gibt und sie nur in die Software eingebaut werden muss. Oder dass man zumindest sowas mal machen kann. Also das ist auch ein Unterschied zu POP3, das IMAP-extensible oder wie haben sie es genannt? Naja, erweiterbar. Also dieses U-Idle kam auch erst später, so weit ich weiß.
Gibt da eben einen Mechanismus, über den der IMAP-Server dann auch sagen kann, welche Features er unterstützt. Und dann kann der Kleine sich überlegen, welches davon er benutzen möchte.
Und eins dieser Features könnte es ja sein, Multi-Flag oder Tags. Tags wäre eigentlich mal praktisch.
Gut, aber könnte, gibt es nicht. Was ist denn hier mit deinem tauben Schlag? Dovkot.
Der das kann?
Erzähl doch mal, was, also ich meine, genau. Fragen wir doch mal so. Was ist denn, was habt ihr denn für Mail-Setups? Das finde ich ja mal jetzt ganz interessant, Daniel. Also wie empfängst du Mail? Wo, mit was und womit liest du es?
Na, ich habe...
Du hast ja auch eigene Domains, ne?
Einen eigenen Mail-Server, genau. Ich habe auch eigene Domains. Und dieser Mail-Server ist eben zuständig. Da kommen wir gleich noch drauf, wie man irgendwie bekannt gibt im Internet, dass ein bestimmtes Server für eine Domain eben zuständig ist und dafür die Mail-Funktion erledigt. Und auf diesem Server schlagen eben die E-Mails auf, werden in einen entsprechenden IMAP-Folder.
Ja, mit welcher Software machst du das? Also mit welcher Software empfängt bei dir die Mail?
Bei mir ist es Postfix, der die Mail empfängt und sie dann weiterleitet, also der sie in einen Mail-Deal speichert und dort wird sie wiederum abgeholt von einem Kurier-IMAP-Server, der für mich ganz gut funktioniert. Und gleichzeitig, weil es eben Mail-Deal ist an der Stelle, kann ich auch mit Programmen darauf zugreifen, die auf dem Server selber laufen. Das ist jetzt genau der Fall, den wir eigentlich hier nicht besprechen wollten, den wir ein bisschen ausgeklammert haben, dass man sich wirklich einloggt auf einen Server und dort E-Mails liest mit einem Programm, in meinem Fall ist es MUT. Es gibt auch PINE oder andere.
Für die Freunde der Kommando-Zeile.
Ja genau, aber das ist wie gesagt nicht der Standardfall und insofern halt auch so ein bisschen handgestrickt. Der Standardfall ist wirklich, dass man dann mit IMAP das abholt, was ich dann auch tue.
Ja gut, aber es geht ja konkret auch um deinen Setup, das ist ja auch interessant. Ja, also in meinem Fall ist es so, dass du auch Ausfix und Kurier und die Möglichkeit lokal auf dem Server selber nochmal mit Programmen ohne IMAP sozusagen draufzugreifen. Das ist ja eigentlich der Punkt. Das Protokoll fällt weg, sondern man hat einen Direktzugriff und das wird dadurch sortiert, dass es eben eine definierte Speicherung der Mails gibt.
Wie ist es da mit Flex? Übernimmt dir Kurier die? Also, mit Mut sind die gelesen, wenn du sie woanders liest, wenn es nicht über IMAP geht.
Genau, das funktioniert ganz gut. Weil eben diese Maledier-Struktur...
Das zulässt dir. Die haben auch Flex da.
Richtig. Aber gleichzeitig kann ich eben auch mit allen Programmen, die IMAP sprechen, auch auf meine Mail zugreifen. Das kann dann Apple Mail sein oder Thunderbird oder sonst irgendwas. Das ist eigentlich total egal. Oder Evolution nutze ich dann auch da drauf und kann mir das dann irgendwie aussuchen.
Oder via Squirrel Mail könnte man auch am Web zugreifen.
Man könnte dann auch, was ich nicht habe, aber man könnte dann auch ein Web-Frontend dafür basteln.
Das ist Squirrel Mail.
Das spricht auf der einen Seite IMAP, also spricht mit einem IMAP-Server und zeigt das halt in einem Web.
Das heißt, der Mail-Delivery-Agent weiß gar nichts davon, dass da ein Web-Frontend ist. Das ist für ihn wie jeder andere Mail-User-Agent auch.
Genau.
Wie jeder andere Mail-Client auch. Wobei die sich aber wahrscheinlich auch schon ein bisschen zu erkennen geben, oder? Diese Mail-Client weiß der Server, wenn da so ein Client kommt, welcher der so ist.
Also das glaube ich das nicht. Ich glaube nicht, dass die das bekannt geben.
Schicken kein Stringnetz.
Das ist eigentlich auch nicht so relevant. Also aus statistischen Gründen vielleicht interessant.
Okay, und du, Dirk? Also ich habe einen Q-Mail als MTA. Also der empfängt die Mail, schreibt sie dann auch in ein Mail dir.
Also das, was bei ihm der Postfix macht, macht bei dir das Q-Mail.
Genau. Dann sitzt da drauf der DoveCut und dann habe ich in der Regel, also ich habe zwei Mail-Setups, einen Mail-Client für private Mail, das ist Thunderbird, und einen für Firmen-E-Mails, das ist Mail-App auf dem Mac, und in der Firma habe ich noch ein Thunderbird auf dem Firmenrechner, der auf beides zugeworfen kann. Also ich habe so ein bisschen so ein Misch-Setup, aber in der Regel Thunderbird und Mail-App. Und ich habe auch noch ein Squirrel-Mail tatsächlich, aber das Squirrel-Mail ist so eine Sache, wenn man viel Mail hat, oder große Folder, der will da immer gleich durchgehen, und zwar bei jedem Mal, wenn man halt den ersten Aufruf macht, und dann dauert es halt so lange unter Umständen. Also erstmal muss man den Speicher hochsetzen von Squirrel-Mail, das ist so eine PHP-Software, wenn ich mich richtig entsinne. Also erstmal den Speicher hochsetzen, damit es überhaupt geht, und wenn man den dann hochgesetzt hat, dann muss man auch noch Timeouts hochsetzen, weil es manchmal 1-2 Minuten dauern kann, bis der die Mails so vorbereitet hat, dass er sie in einem Web-Content anzeigen kann. Oder man muss eine sehr gute Folder-Struktur haben, dass immer nur in den aktuellen Folder, in die man reingucken will, nur so 1000 Mails drin sind oder so.
So Web-Mail-Client sind nicht wirklich dafür gebaut, in großen Mengen an Mail umzugehen.
In dem Fall ist es die Verbindung aus IMAP und Web-Mail. Also man könnte sicher einen Web-Mail frontend und mit IMAP zusammen so machen, dass es performt.
Oh, sicherlich. Google ist das ja auch gelungen.
Was auch immer die von Ansatz fahren, die haben wahrscheinlich eher den IMAP oben draufgeflanscht und so. Aber wie auch immer.
Naja, den Eindruck habe ich ja gerade nicht, dass sie da IMAP machen.
Die haben eigentlich ihre Datenbank und da machen sie ihr Webinterface drauf. Ich meine, die sind halt eine Suchmaschine.
Nichts anderes ist ja auch nicht. Ich glaube doch nicht, dass sie wirklich IMAP benutzen, intern, wo das schon so unterschiedlich ist.
Das meinte Daniel ja auch, dass sie eben gerade IMAP hinterher dran geflanscht haben, weil die User alle IMAP haben wollten. Das dauerte ja auch eine Weile, bis du IMAP hattest.
Ja, ich wollte das auch haben, aber ich finde es noch nicht wirklich benutzbar.
Ich benutze es auch nicht.
Es ist auch nicht besonders stabil und das ist sehr schade. Das führt aber nur dazu, dass ich diesen Gmail-Account eigentlich auch nicht benutze.
Genau, ich habe auch noch einen Gmail-Account, den benutze ich aber nur, um Mailinglisten zu lesen, die auch Google-relevant sind, also die Android-Google-Groups oder Java-Passiv-Google-Groups. Also sowas lese ich mit Gmail.
Wer Google es eh schon kennt, dann macht man...
Genau, dann sage ich denen höchstens, dass mich das auch interessiert, was sie da haben.
Ja, jetzt gibt es noch so einiges, was ich ganz gerne hinterfragen möchte, nämlich auch hier die Software, die ihr eingesetzt habt, finde ich nochmal ganz interessant. Aber bevor wir das machen, können wir vielleicht nochmal auf dieses... Eine Mail wird verschickt im Internet, nochmal ein bisschen genauer zu sprechen kommen. Also, denn es spielt ja auch noch ein anderer Dienst da eine sehr große Rolle, nämlich DNS. Also, das Namens-Raum-System des Internets. Ihr kennt das alle, ihr benutzt das jederzeit. Ihr gebt irgendwas in euren Google-Pauser ein oder wo auch immer und dann wird halt der Name aufgelöst. Aber in diesem Fall geht es ja nicht nur um Internet-Adressen, sondern auch diese ganze Arithmetik, wem schicke ich denn jetzt eigentlich Mail wohin, steht ja im DNS mit dran. Wenn ich also nun eine Mail verschicke an dich, Daniel, oder an dich, Dirk, von meinem Kleindaus, dann geht das halt erstmal zu meinem MTA. Das hat man ja nun schon. Aber was macht der dann? Wie findet der sozusagen den anderen MTA, dem er jetzt diese Mail schicken muss? Also was ist quasi die Postleitzahl bei E-Mail?
Okay, also ich sollte ganz kurz nochmal darauf eingehen, dein Mailserver, bei dem du deine Mail an mich hinterlässt, der stellt fest zunächst mal, dass es kein lokaler Adressat ist. Also kein lokaler Empfänger ist. Also dass ich nicht auf demselben Server einen Mail-Account habe wie du. Und das wiederum bedingt, dass du dich in irgendeiner Form diesem Mailserver gegenüber authentifiziert hast und sagen kannst, ich bin übrigens berechtigt, eine Mail bei dir abzugeben, die nicht für sich selber ist und die du bitte...
Das war aber auch nicht immer so.
Ja, das war auch lange Zeit...
Früher war das mal ganz anders und dann kam Spam und dann hat sich das ganz schnell geändert.
Also man muss eben dafür sorgen, dass das klar ist, dass ich das darf, dass du das darfst in dem Fall.
Genau. Das heißt, ich brauche einen Username und Passwort.
Genau, es gibt auch noch andere Konstruktionen, die nennen sich POP before SMTP oder SMTP after POP. Also es wird halt noch verwendet, deswegen sollten wir es vielleicht auch ansprechen. Die Idee dahinter ist, da POP und IMAP eine Authentifizierung automatisch eingebaut haben, also die mit Username und Passwort funktioniert, kann man diese Informationen eben hernehmen, kann sagen, ok, derjenige hat sich jetzt gerade die IP-Adresse, hat sich per POP oder per IMAP angemeldet, hier auf meinem Mail-Delivery-Agent gerade eben. Und dann sagen wir mal, diese IP-Adresse, von der die Anfrage kam, darf jetzt für 5 Minuten oder so E-Mails bei mir auch abladen und entsprechend Mail verschicken. Hat natürlich, ist natürlich eine Krücke, hat natürlich eine ganze Menge Nachteile. Unter anderem ist es so, dass diese...
Ja, es muss vor allem, also MTA und MDA müssen dann auch ein zusammenhängendes System sein, das ja nicht immer sind.
Das kommt noch dazu, genau. Und ja, genau, das wird dann eben mit ganz viel Pearl und so erschlagen. Und, naja, und...
POP-Films lesen.
Und naja, also es hat natürlich mehrere Nachteile, das hat man vielleicht ganz kurz noch erklären. Also es hat natürlich den Nachteil, dass diese IP-Adressen, gerade von den Dial-up-Netzwerken und so weiter, die sind natürlich temporär. Das heißt, wenn sich derjenige, der gerade eine IP, also gerade eben sich per POP identifiziert hat, dann seine IP-Adresse verliert, weil sein DSL Disconnect macht und diese IP-Adresse Sekunden später an einen anderen User geht, dann kann der theoretisch, obwohl er mit diesem Server gar nichts zu tun hat, natürlich dort wieder E-Mails abwerfen.
Aber das ist aber sehr...
Also du kannst das halt nicht mehr, weil du halt eine neue Adresse hast. Du musst dann wieder POP machen.
Man kriegt halt so eine Fehlermeldung und weiß nicht, was es soll.
Das kommt dazu, ja. Und dazu kommt auch noch, dass diese NAT-Netzwerke dafür sorgen, dass du nach außen hin halt auch eine IP-Adresse hast, obwohl deine ganze WG oder deine ganze Firma halt irgendwie keine Ahnung aus wie vielen Computern besteht. Und all diese Computer dürfen dann eben auch Mail abliefern, weil der Mail-Server das ja nicht unterscheiden kann.
Aber mal ehrlich, wird das jetzt noch so viel gemacht? Das war doch nur so eine Übergangsphase, wo Leute entweder nicht in der Lage waren oder die Software nicht in der Lage waren, diese Authentifizierung gegenüber dem SMTP-Server durchzuführen. Und mittlerweile ist das doch wirklich überall drin.
Nein, also ich bin jetzt nicht ganz sicher, aber es war bis vor kurzem noch so, dass einige große Provider das auch wirklich noch in Verwendung hatten, dieses System.
Ich habe das auch gehört, gerade vor ein paar Tagen, dass, ich weiß nicht, ob es gmx oder web.de war, dass die sowas tatsächlich noch machen. Ich dachte auch, dass wir gäbe es nicht mehr. Und das wäre, ich habe es auch völlig verdrängt.
Nee, es ist ja auch gut so, dass es in Vergessenheit gerät, weil die Realität da draußen ist wirklich zum Schreien. Es ist nicht so schön, ja.
Wir ignorieren jetzt mal die Realität und gucken uns mal an, wie das wirklich läuft. Also wenn die Mail jetzt zu dir kommen soll.
Also es gibt dann eben auch diese entsprechende Verschlüsselung auf dem SMTP-Kanal und eine Authentifizierung vor allem. Also wenn man authentifiziert über SMTP, sollte man besser auch verschlüsseln, weil sonst kann man das eben mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit irgendwie mitlesen.
Aber auch das ging ja nicht immer. Also SMTP kannte lange Zeit keine Verschlüsselung.
Und die initiale Verbindung kennt auch immer noch keine Verschlüsselung. Also die initiale Verbindung auf Port 25, was der SMTP-Port ist, ist immer Klartext, bis dann einer Start-TLS sagt, ich glaube der Kleine sagt das, das ist gar nicht ganz genau, und dann geht es los mit der Verschlüsselung. Also in Band, Start der Verschlüsselung.
Oder du connectest auf Port 465, wenn du weißt, dass dort irgendwie ein entsprechendes Läufer läuft. Genau, und dann kannst du auch... Gut, aber überspringen wir vielleicht schon wieder eine ganze Menge Punkte. Das sollten wir vielleicht der Reihe nach machen. Also wir gehen jetzt mal davon aus, dass du dich deinem Mailserver gegenüber, als jemand dargestellt hast, der Mails abladen darf. Ja. Wie das genau passiert, kann man vielleicht noch.
Ich denke auch, für diese Verschlüsselungsteile ist nochmal so ein ganz eigenes Fass. Das soll man jetzt erstmal nicht aufmachen. Ja, weil mir geht es ja jetzt erstmal um dieses, wie finden sich die alle miteinander. Und das hat ja wenig damit zu tun, wie ich mich meinem Mailserver gegenüber authentifiziere. Gehen wir einfach davon aus, er kennt mich, wir haben ein gutes Verhältnis, mein Mailserver und ich. Und er nimmt mir einfach diese Mail ab. Und jetzt schaut er einfach, reißt er so das Fenster auf, guckt in das Internet und sagt, oh, it's full of stars. Wohin?
Also da gibt es natürlich jetzt zunächst mal diese sogenannten MX-Einträge im DNS, die für eine Domain angeben, wer der Mail-Exchanger ist.
Daniel at example.com.
Genau, example.com hat also ein MX-Eintrag oder mehrere MX-Einträge, je nachdem.
MX-Eintrag heißt Mail-Exchanger. Im DNS-System ein Eintrag für die Domain example.com, die jetzt nicht eine IP-Adresse ist, sondern eine Information, wer holt die Mail ab. Oder wer nimmt sie an.
Genau, und es sind sogar zwei Informationen. Nämlich einerseits der Name desjenigen, der sie annimmt, und eine Priorität. Und je kleiner die Priorität, desto... Also der, der die kleinste hat, hat sozusagen die höchste.
Der, der die kleinste hat, hat die höchste... Die kleinste Zahl heißt höchste Priorität.
Genau, der kriegt es am Schluss eh. Man sollte zuerst dem versuchen, es zu schicken, der die kleinste zahle. Wenn das nicht geht, dann schickt man es mit einer etwas größeren Zahl, und der schickt es.
Das ist dafür gemacht, dass es eine Ausfallsicherheit gibt, falls der Mailserver down ist.
Wobei faktisch wird das, glaube ich, gar nicht mehr so richtig genutzt.
Na, es ist so, dass wenn mehrere Mailserver die selbe...
Genau, dann wird es zufällig. Damit kann man Load-Balancing machen.
Genau, dann ist laut Spezifikation, laut RFC, der sendende Mailserver verpflichtet, einen zufälligen Eintrag aus diesen gleich priorisierten Einträgen rauszusuchen und den dann zu kontaktieren. Weil das die Idee dahinter ist. Man sagt, das hier sind meine 10 MX-Records, schick es an irgendeinen von denen. Die haben alle die selber Priorität. Das ist total egal.
Und die haben auch wegen des Spams nicht mehr unterschiedliche Prioritäten. Weil sonst könnte man nämlich unter Umständen den Austricksen, in dem man nämlich... Manchmal war es früher so, dass der, der eine höhere Priorität hatte, tatsächlich nur ein Ausfallserver war. Der war gar nicht in der Administration desjenigen, der die Mail schlusslich...
Also eine niedrigere Priorität, eine höhere Zahl.
Genau. Der wusste gar nicht über die User zum Beispiel. Der wusste gar nicht, welche User es gibt, weil er halt in einer anderen Verwaltungseinheit... Also der wurde von einer anderen Person verwaltet. Und...
Und deswegen hat das alle angenommen und war nicht gegen Spam gehärtet. Und deswegen haben die Spammer dann ganz gerne ihre...
Die höheren, also die mit der niedrigeren Priorität.
Das ist aber wieder erstaunlich, nicht? Also früher war das Internet ja so ein Garten Eden, wo sich alle vertraut haben und wo es nur gute Menschen gab. Und gerade diese Mail-Ausfallserver war ja da nicht selten bei dem Internet-Service-Provider, wo man so angeschlossen war. Weil, wenn die Leitung gekappt war von dem ISP zu einem selbst, kam ja schon mal vor, dass das alles nicht so gut funktionierte, dann mussten die Mails zumindest keinen großen Umweg gehen, sondern sie wurden einfach beim ISP abgeliefert und dann, nachdem die Verbindung wieder hergestellt war, sogar die Klage hinterher übertragen. Ach, hier übrigens, hier ist noch ein Bag of Mail für dich. Aber auch da hat Spam wieder die Tür zugemacht.
Ja, und ich meine, dieses Band führt auch dieses gesamte Loadbalancing so einigermaßen ad absurdum. Denn wenn die Spammer ihren Spam nicht bei einem der Mail-Server loswerden, dann versuchen sie halt den nächsten. Das heißt, man stellt dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, tatsächlich drei Server dahin, die alle irgendwie......alle belästigt werden... .und die dann alle von den gleichen Spamern irgendwie gleichermaßen belästigt werden. Insofern macht Spam dann eine ganze Menge natürlich am Konzept kaputt. Also das ist dann die Information, die dein Mail-Server braucht, um mir at example.com eine Mail zukommen zu lassen. Da steht dann also ein Name drin.
Da steht jetzt drin postman.example.com ist der Computer, der die Mail annimmt.
Richtig, genau. Das wiederum ist natürlich übers DNS in eine IP-Adresse auflösbar. Und als solchen kann man diesen anderen Mail-Transfer-Agent dann eben kontaktieren.
Das heißt, das macht dann mein MTA, dem ich meine Mail geschickt habe.
Standardmäßig auf Port 25. Davon gehen alle aus, dass dort irgendwie im E-Mail ausgetauscht wird auf Port 25. Und dann sagt der, also dein MTA, meinem MTA hier, ich habe hier eine Mail für dich, die ist von hier tim.ccc.de und soll gehen an daniel.example.com und nimm doch mal an. Und wenn mein MX-Server, also mein Mailserver als MX-Record eingetragen ist, für example.com, dann wird er mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit, es sei denn er ist falsch konfiguriert, auch sagen, jawohl, diese Mail, die ist an einem meiner lokalen Adressaten hier.
Also im Idealfall wird das sozusagen noch während der Annahme auch überprüft. Das war ja früher auch nicht unbedingt immer so.
Während die Verbindung noch besteht, ja.
Genau. Also ja, richtig. Also während noch darüber gesprochen wird, von wem die Mail ist und an wem die Mail geht, wird das eben überprüft. Und dann gibt es einen entsprechenden Fehlercode, falls da irgendwas schiefgegangen ist.
Zu dem Port 25. Also wenn ich jetzt mit meinem Laptop unterwegs bin und ich habe meinen eigenen Server, meinen eigenen Mail-Server konfiguriert. Der ist natürlich nicht auf meinem Laptop sein, der ist irgendwo. Und ich will jetzt meinem Mail-Server, an dem ich mich authentifizieren kann, Mail schicken, damit er sie dann in die Welt schickt. Dann scheitert das sehr häufig in Hotels daran, dass in solchen Public-Wi-Fi-Infrastrukturen oder auch in Universitäten in Deutschland sehr verbreitet genau dieser Port gesperrt ist.
Darin kannst du was tun.
Ja, aber ich meine, die Intention ist ja sozusagen, was ist die Intention und ist das überhaupt sinnvoll?
Es soll kein Spam verschickt werden durch die Intention.
Also Spam kommt eben zum ganz großen Teil von Rechnern, die kaputt sind. Naja, von Bot-Netz halt. Also von irgendwelchen, hauptsächlich Windows-Maschinen, die eben mit Viren und Würmern voll sind und dadurch eben in die Lage versetzt wurden, Spam durchs Netz zu treten. Und diese Viren und Würmer konnektieren eben andere Mailsaber auf POT25.
Ja, was heißt denn andere? Also ihre?
Nee, nee, fremde. Ziel-MTAs, um den Spam halt loszuwerden.
Wo sie sich aber auch einloggen.
Nein, nein, nein.
Die machen das ja direkt.
Die gehen direkt zu meinem example.com und sagen, wir wissen ja über das DNS, wir wissen ja, wo die Mail hin soll. Also wir kennen den DNS-Rekord dafür, den MX-DNS-Rekord. Und dann gehen wir doch einfach zu dem direkt und sagen, hier, ich habe eine Mail für Daniel, der zum example.com kommt. Nimm mal an.
Spam wird immer direkt versendet. Der Spammer sucht sich nicht einen, also doch manchmal schon, aber in der Regel nimmt er nicht seinen eigenen Mail-Server, um die Mail zu verschicken, sondern er nimmt irgendwelche ge-hijackten...
Oder halt diesen Open Relay. Wenn jemand so ein Ding falsch konfiguriert hat und der wirklich offen war. Aber ich meine, hilft das nun wirklich?
Port-25-Sperrung?
Bis zu einem gewissen Maße vielleicht schon. Das ist aber auch unpraktisch. Aber in deinem Fall, wenn das dein eigener Mail-Server ist, dann mach doch einfach noch einen Port auf. Und wenn es sein muss, mach Port 80 auf. Der wird garantiert nicht gesperrt sein. Und verschick deine Mail von deinem Notebook an Port 80 auf deinem Mail-Server. Also ich zum Beispiel habe auch noch einen zweiten Port offen. Und das ist auch der einzige, der SMTP-Auth irgendwie erlaubt. Nämlich 25-25, weil bei mir das Problem ist, dass ich so viel Spam kriege, dass Port 25 häufig gar nicht benutzbar ist für mich. Oder manchmal eine Minute oder zwei dauert, bis da eine Mail angenommen wird. Weil da die 40 Verbindungen oder 100 Verbindungen, die ich gleichzeitig zulasse, schon verbraucht sind. Und deshalb habe ich einen eigenen SMTP-D auf einem eigenen Port, nämlich 25-25, mit SMTP-Auth, gestartet, um dort meine Mails abzuliefern.
Ja, aber wenn ich jetzt mein Mail kleint, aber wenn das sozusagen mein Mailedienstleister ist und ich habe überhaupt keinen Einfluss darauf, auf welchen Port das ist, also wenn ich jetzt so GMX oder so, dann kann ich, obwohl ich mich korrekt authentifiziere, nicht Mail verschicken aus einem solchen Netz.
Das ist richtig, ja.
Das ist eigentlich verkrüppelt, das Netz.
Also ich meine, die meisten Mailedienstleister lassen mittlerweile diesen Port 465, 465 auch zu, weil das eben der SMTP-S-Port ist, also sprich SMTP mit einem entsprechenden SSL-Layer drüber.
Und ist das nicht für Spammer nutzbar?
Na ja, richtig, das ist auch rechenintensiv und so. Die wollen lieber im Klartext ihre Mail loswerden.
Welche Portnummer?
Du meinst, in dem Moment, wo alle SMTP-Server auf SSL umgestellt sind, würde man dem Spam schon mal eine gelbe Karte zeigen?
Na ja, das ist natürlich immer so ein Kampf gegen Windmühler. Das kommen wir später nochmal genauer zu, was man alles gegen Spam tun kann. Ich finde, wir können uns hier auch immer ein bisschen einstreuen. Es gibt mehrere Möglichkeiten, aber letztlich basieren die meisten leider darauf, dass die Spammer eben nachlegen müssen und entsprechend andere Protokolle implementieren müssen oder andere Vorgehensweisen implementieren müssen, um dann wiederum einen entsprechenden Schutz auszuhebeln.
Das heißt, wenn man jetzt wirklich viel unterwegs ist und man hat das Problem, dass man einen Mail-Provider sich ausgesucht hat, der derzeit nur auf Port 25 zu haben ist, um Mail zu verschicken und man befindet sich aber die ganze Zeit in irgendwelchen schwindeligen Hotels mit wacky WLAN-Angeboten, dann ist man ganz gut bedient, entweder seinen Mail-Anbieter mal anzuschreiben und zu sagen, hier hör mal, mach doch mal Port 465 auf, damit wir hier mal ein bisschen klarkommen oder denkt dir sonst irgendeinen anderen aus oder vielleicht mal einen Mail-Provider wechseln.
Ja, oder du musst halt als, also in diesen Fällen dann entweder auf einen, ich weiß nicht, man kann auf einen VPN zurückgreifen und dann eben seinen, den Account seiner Firma dann nutzen, indem man den über das VPN eben anspricht, das würde gehen oder man muss in solchen Situationen dann halt doch auf irgendwelche Webfrontlines zurückgreifen und so. Aber es ist ein Problem, das stimmt schon, auch ein strukturelles.
Ja, stimmt schon auch. Also ich muss sagen, bei diesem blöden Hotel WLANs, also wenn ich auf sowas treffe, dann klicke ich mir eigentlich immer sofort wieder ein VPN-Account. Das macht die Sache dann doch deutlich entspannter. Und der ist jetzt richtig für SMTP-S alluziert. SMTP-S heißt, dass man nach wie vor SMTP spricht, aber von vornherein gleich verschlüsselt ist. Das heißt, es ist analog zu HTTPS. Das heißt, schon das erste Byte, was darüber geht, ist Teil der ganzen Krypto-Geschichte. Das heißt aber dann auch, wenn man sich selber sowas aufsetzt, muss man dann auch über entsprechende Zertifikate verstehen.
Ja, da muss man den ganzen Chichi und dieses C-APL verstehen und das ist alles immer ganz furchtbar.
Was unterscheidet dir denn jetzt diese Verschlüsselung von Anfang an versus Verschlüsselung im Rahmen des Protokollaufbaus?
Der Vorteil ist halt, dass man es auch über Portfolio machen kann.
Wie funktioniert denn diese TLS-dynamische Krypto-Geschichte?
Das ist auch SSL, nur fängt es halt später an.
Und wann fängt es an?
Wenn einer startet, TLS sagt. Ich glaube, der Client sagt.
Das sollten wir ganz kurz durchspielen, wie denn die Kommunikation zwischen einem Client und einem Mailserver so funktioniert auf SMTP-Basis. Das erste, was der Client dem Mailserver gegenüber sagt, ist Hallo, also gut erzogene Mailserver.
Also die reden ja in ASCII miteinander. Man kann das ja mitlesen.
Man kann da auch ganz normal mit einem Telnet auf Port 25 eines entsprechenden Mailservers connecten und das einfach ausprobieren. Auf Port 25 wird eben von Anfang an zum nächsten Mal nur standardmäßig unverschlüsseltes SMTP gesprochen und deswegen kann man das auch einfach eintippen. Und wie gesagt, Mailserver sagen zunächst mal Hallo oder mehr klein sagen erst mal dem Server Hallo mit dem HELLO-Kommando und geben dabei an, wie sie dann selber so heißen, also ihren Fully Qualified Domain Name. Und daraufhin antwortet der Server dann ebenfalls mit einem Hallo und sagt, schönen guten Tag, ich bin der und der. Worum geht es denn? Man kann an der Stelle, also eigentlich beweisen müssen, die sich das nicht, das ist nur so eine Behauptung.
Ja, ja, also man sagt einfach HELLO und dann irgendwas. In der Regel ist es wurscht, was man da sagt.
Ja, na gut, das kommt auf die Konfiguration des Servers an. Man kann da eben in der Konfiguration auch sagen, wenn derjenige nicht mit der IP derjenige ist, der behauptet zu sein, dann weisen sie sofort mal ab. Weil auf sich haben wir ja schon mal gar keinen Bock.
Das heißt, man muss auch darauf achten, dass man dieses Reverse-Look ab von seiner IP-Adresse richtig hat.
Genau, also es gibt eine Fülle von Regelsätzen, die stimmen müssen, um mit den meisten großen Mailservern überhaupt noch reden zu können, weil die genau auf solche Protokoll-Verletzungen ziemlich allergisch reagieren.
Ich will es ja nicht als Protokoll-Verletzung bezeichnen.
Aber wie auch immer.
Na, laut SMTP ist es da wirklich egal, was man da sagt. Also es ist eine Konvention zu sagen, wer man ist. Aber manchmal weiß man auch gar nicht, wer man ist. Wenn man hinter einem Nat hängt, weiß man unter Umständen gar nicht, wer man ist. Vielleicht gibt man eine IP-Adresse an, die man selber gerade auf seinem Interface gefunden hat, aber für den Server kommt man von einer ganz anderen IP-Adresse und dann kracht es auch manchmal nicht. Und deshalb finde ich es übertrieben, auf den Helostring irgendetwas zuzugeben. Ich habe auch keines meiner Mail-Setups so konfiguriert, dass der Helostring irgendeine Bedeutung hat.
Ja, also ich bloque damit irgendwie den Großteil meines Spams. Also wenn du da schon mal irgendwie keinen Fully Qualified Domain nimmst, sondern irgendeinen...
Aber wie machst du denn das mit deinem Rechner, wenn du jetzt hier hinter so einem Nat klebst?
Na ja, also es gibt natürlich Kollateralschäden bei dem Kampf gegen den Spam-Test.
Das heißt, du kannst jetzt keine Mail verschicken?
Ich kann aus deinem Netz hier vermutlich an meinen Server keine Mail absetzen.
Deshalb hattest du deinen Mut offen.
Hast du dann auch noch so eine VPN-Flucht-Taste, so in die Fälle?
Na ja, nee, ich hab ja also mit meinem Mail-Programm auf meinem Rechner hier, kann ich natürlich. Aber jetzt, wenn ich einfach nur Telnet auf meinem Serverport 25 mache aus deinem DSL-Netzwerk.
Du machst wahrscheinlich auch direkt SSL und sagst einfach Hallo, ich bin User, Name und Passwort. Und dann ist das ja eh alles egal. Gut, na wie auch immer.
Also auf jeden Fall, hello. HELLO ist so das Kommando, das halt standardmäßig irgendwie schon immer gesprochen wurde. Die neue Variante davon, so neu ist sie noch auch nicht mehr, ist EHLO. Und dann sagt man eben, EHLO ist super oder? E-SMPP.
Das ist so ein richtiger Nerd-Joke. Man sagt irgendwie nicht mehr Hallo, man sagt irgendwie EHLO. Oder ELO. Okay und dann?
Und dann antwortet der Server mit einer extended response in dem Fall und gibt seine Funktionen preis. Also sagt eben, was er so alles kann. Und da stehen dann so Dinge drin, wie zum Beispiel ich bin in der Lage, Start TLS auszuführen.
Also dokumentiert so sein Featureset.
Genau.
Wenn er halt kein TLS kann, dann wird er diese Zeit ja nicht ausgeben, aber dieses Server hier sagt eben kein Problem. Also wenn du magst, können wir gerne auch für Schlüssel quatschen. Und wenn der entsprechende Client, das kann jetzt ein Mail-User-Agent sein oder ein anderer MTA, sagt irgendwie ja, TLS kann ich auch, ist eigentlich auch irgendwie cooler, weil dann ist auch egal, was so zwischen uns ist im Internet, lass uns mal verschlüsselt weiter quatschen. Und dann sagt er eben Start TLS und dann geht's ab diesem Moment verschlüsselt weiter.
Trotzdem ist diese ganze Zertifikatsgeschichte an der Stelle genauso, als hätte man gleich damit angefangen.
Aber dann musst du halt wissen, dass der andere Mailserver eben auf Port 4, 6, 5 seine sichere TLS-verschlüsselte Variante an SMTPs hat.
Genau, und so kann man das einfach rausfinden. Ach, du kannst ja auch Verschlüsselungen, dann machen wir das mal. Okay, ist aber optional.
Da gibt's noch eine interessante Anekdote. Ich weiß gar nicht, wer das hatte, aber es kam mal so ein Protokoll durch, dass irgendwie das Start-TLS-Kommando verschwunden ist bei einer Übertragung zwischen zwei Rechnern und somit verhindert man effektiv, dass noch verschlüsselt werden kann, weil in der Regel verzichten die dann auf TLS.
Ja, das war ein großer Provider, dessen Namen wir vielleicht nicht unbedingt erwähnen sollen, aber ein großer deutscher Internetprovider hat sich erdreistet, eben in das Protokoll einzugreifen und das Start-TLS, das von den Servern zurückkam, mit xxx zu überschreiben, woraufhin die entsprechenden Endgeräte, das waren mobile Endgeräte, eben gesagt haben, naja TLS gibt es nicht, dann ist das blöd, dann müssen wir jetzt irgendwie unverschlüsselt weiter quatschen, was denen natürlich ganz recht war, weil dann konnten sie sehen, was da eigentlich übertragen wurde. Eine ziemliche Frechheit.
Theoretisch könnte man seinen Client auch so konfigurieren, dass er dann gar nicht mehr weiter redet, wenn er kein TLS machen darf.
Es spricht eigentlich eine ganze Menge dafür, SMTP-S zu verwenden.
Ja, natürlich.
Kann man mal festhalten. So, als Empfehlung.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist man dann doch ein bisschen alleine.
Fest, dass doch ein Großteil mittlerweile, ich kann es jetzt nicht in Prozenten ausgerechnet, aber doch wirklich viele andere Server, die so ankommen und Mails abliefern wollen, sind TLS, das finde ich auch gut.
Hier ist aber statt TLS explizit dann ein Aufruf, nachdem sie über Port 25 connected haben.
Ja, also das mache ich ja auch. Mein Server versucht auch erstmal TLS zu machen.
Gibt es denn auch eine Möglichkeit, andere MTAs dazu zu bringen, gleich SMTP-S mit einem zu sprechen?
Ja, es gab da mal eine Möglichkeit.
Das könnte man über TLS machen.
In seinem MX-Rekord müsste man das sozusagen als Zusatzinformation hinterlegen.
Ja, es gab da auch.
Das ist doch bestimmt wieder so ein ominöser TXT-Rekord.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich, ja. Finde ich noch mal raus und schreibe das dann noch mal in das Blog. Weiß ich jetzt gerade nicht mehr. Es gab irgendeine Möglichkeit, rauszufinden, dass der andere auf Port 465 auf jeden Fall auch schon SMTP-S quatscht und dann direkt daran verbindet. Aber eigentlich gibt es auch keinen Grund, nicht mit Start-TLS zu arbeiten. Ich sehe keinen technischen Nachteil dadurch.
Nee, sollen alle machen.
Und wenn man jetzt seinen Mail-Server so konfigurieren würde, dass man nur über Verschlüsselung annimmt, wie viele legitime E-Mails pro Tag würde man dann so aussperren?
Ja, natürlich, das ist eine sehr interessante Idee. Nur da war halt diese Sache mit den Kollateralschärfen wahrscheinlich dann extrem hoch werden. Also ich würde das gerne wissen, aber ich würde es ungern ausprobieren, weil E-Mail ist halt schon ein bisschen zu wichtig.
Das ist auch so eins der Grundprobleme in dieser ganzen Spam-Bekämpfung, dass sich einfach keiner traut, mal wirklich was auszuprobieren, weil in dem Moment die E-Mail schon weg ist.
Na das Problem ist, du kannst es auch nicht auf so Testdomains ausprobieren, weil auf denen im Zweifel nur Spam aufschlägt und keine ernsthafte E-Mail mehr. Und dann kann man darüber auch wieder keine Aussage treffen.
Man müsste dann bestimmte Leute halt bestimmte E-Mail-Adressen rausgeben, von denen man weiß, dass sie ihren Server entsprechend konfiguriert haben.
Oder man müsste so ein simuliertes System von Servern haben, die sich einfach nach ähnlichen Pattern, wie das auch sonst passiert, so Workgroup-Flow-Simulations-mäßig sich E-Mails zuschicken.
Also verfirmen könnte man das intern vielleicht.
Aber naja, dann weiß man es aber auch nur für die, die man sich selber schickt.
Das ist alles Quatsch. Es gibt halt bei dem ganzen Kampf gegen Spam mehrere Möglichkeiten. Unter anderem kann man sich viele Details dieser E-Mail genau angucken. Also wenn sie dann mal eingegangen ist und dann eine Gewichtung vornehmen kann. Also sagen, diese Mail ist per TLS reingekommen. Die ist im Zweifel kein Spam. Und gibt dem dann ein paar Pluspunkte. Dann gibt es vielleicht ein paar andere Negativpunkte. Aber insgesamt kommt dann halt eine Gesamtwichtung dabei raus. Und an der macht man dann fest, dass es sich wohl um Spam handelt oder nicht.
Hast du denn noch so ein explizites Spam-System mit drin?
Ja, ja.
Das sollten wir dann vielleicht noch mal kurz nachtragen.
Was ist das? Na, es gibt da unterschiedliche Features. Postfix selber bietet da eine ganze Latte an unterschiedlichen Herangehensweisen.
Du benutzt die Spam-Features von Postfix oder du benutzt nochmal eine separate Spam-Testsoftware?
Na, also zunächst mal muss man sagen, das ganze Problem mit Spam fängt damit an, dass man Mail überhaupt annimmt. Die Wurzel alles übelt. Tatsächlich, und zwar aus mehreren Gründen. Zum einen glaubt nämlich der Spammer dann, dass diese Mail auch wirklich durchgegangen ist. Ich weiß jetzt nicht im Detail, wie diese Spam-Bots funktionieren oder diese ganzen Bot-Netz funktionieren, aber ich könnte mir schon vorstellen, dass die Information, ob der selber nun gesagt hat, ok, alles klar, Mail ist angenommen, schönen Tag noch, dass die wiederum abfügt, dass er mehr schickt. Natürlich, ja. Weil, wenn die davon ausgehen, ok, unser System funktioniert soweit, und diese Adresse irgendwie nimmt offensichtlich auch E-Mails an, also kriegt die jetzt noch mehr. Weil, wenn die Mail dann abgelehnt wird, haben die ja auch keinen Spaß. Das ist mal der erste Fall, warum Mail anzunehmen schon mal gar keine gute Idee ist. Der nächste Grund dafür ist, dass laut SMTP-Standard ein Mail-Server, wenn er dann am Ende der Kommunikation, also da passiert jetzt noch mehr nach diesem Hilo oder Extended-Hilo, wird dann eben ausgehandelt. Ich habe eine Mail, die ist von dem und dem, und die geht da und da hin, und würde jetzt gerne mal die Daten schicken. Und wenn am Ende dieser Kommunikation die Mail angenommen wurde von dem Server und der dann eben mit einem Return-Code von 250 sagt, alles klar, Mail ist jetzt bei mir gequeued und ich kümmere mich darum, dann ist diese Mail in der Verantwortung des Servers. Der muss dafür sorgen, dass diese Mail entweder zugestellt wird oder entsprechend ein, wenn sie nicht zustellbar ist, einen Bounce generiert wird, der dann zurückgeschickt wird. Eins von beiden muss passieren. Sie einfach zu löschen ist...
Kann man auch machen. Ich mache das inzwischen. Wirklich?
Also eigentlich ist es nicht in Ordnung.
Nichts kostet zu viel Prozessorzeit, die ganzen Mails zu bearbeiten und zu benutzen.
Das Problem ist, dass du wahrscheinlich zu viele davon annimmst. Also was man halt tun kann, ist, dass man sich genau überlegt, was ist das für eine Mail, wo kommt die her? Es gibt einen sehr unschönen Effekt, der auch von Spamern seit Jahren mittlerweile ausgenutzt wird. Das ist dieses Backscatter, das darauf basiert, dass die Return-Adressen, also die vermeintlichen Absender-Adressen von einem Spam, geforged sind. Das bedeutet also, die sind nicht echt.
Also die sind nicht echt im Sinne von...
Nicht von dem, in dem sie es ansprechen.
Es kam nicht von dem, aber das sind schon gültige E-Mail-Adressen.
Genau. Also ich könnte zum Beispiel sagen, ich habe eine Mail, die geht irgendwie an blaafasl.example.com und die ist von tim.signerdomain.de. Und mein Server nimmt die jetzt erstmal an und sagt, da gucken wir mal, ist gut, 250, irgendwie Mail ist bei mir gequeued, mache ich dann. Dann kommt der Server später drauf, dass es blaafasl.example.com gar nicht gibt und will eine Antwort formulieren und formuliert die eben an... Richtig, so. Und konnektiert als ordentlicher im Internet registrierter Mailserver eben deinen MX-Record und liefert bei dir dann diesen Spam-Mail ab.
Als Bounce.
Als Bounce, ja.
Tut aber in der Regel den gesamten Spam mit rein.
Natürlich, ja, weil man will wissen, worum es noch ging. Und dann hast du also den ganzen Mist unten in der E-Mail kleben. Und weil die eben auch so technisch aussieht und eventuell wirklich irgendein Problem beschreiben könnte, liest sie dir am Ende auch noch durch.
Und damit hat die Spam dann sozusagen auch schon indirekt wiederum ihren Weg erreicht.
Genau, die hat dich erreicht. Und für dich war der Spam auch, weil der Spammer wusste, dass die eigentliche Adresse gar nicht existiert, unter Umständen.
Und aus dem Grund ist es eine schlechte Idee, Mail überhaupt erst anzunehmen. Man sollte also diese Spamme, wenn du also schon wissen kannst, während der SMTP-Kommunikation, dass die Zieladresse gar nicht gültig ist, dann triggst du einfach die Kommunikation ab und sagst so, nö, gibts bei mir nicht, geh weg.
Und das ist übrigens auch was, was früher anders war, denn früher hat man die Mail lieber angenommen, obwohl es die Adresse nicht gab, um dem Server, der sie bei einem eingeliefert hat, nicht preiszugeben, dass es einen bestimmten User oder eine bestimmte Adresse überhaupt gibt.
Ja genau, das war mal ein Sicherheitsvideo.
Genau, heute ist es die Katastrophe. Also wirklich die Katastrophe.
Da fällt mir noch was anderes auf und korrigiert mich, wenn ich da vielleicht irgendwas übersehen habe. Aber meiner Wahrnehmung nach ist ja eigentlich das E-Mail-System im Internet insofern eine volle Katastrophe, weil das wahrscheinlich so ziemlich das einzige Protokollsystem ist, in dem es keine klar definierten Fehlermeldungen gibt. Also Fehlermeldungen im Sinne von zum Beispiel so einen Bounce. Ich rede jetzt nicht von einer Fehlermeldungsnummer innerhalb von SMTP. Das ist alles wohldefiniert. Was ich meine ist, wenn so eine Mail nicht zugestellt worden kann, dann erhalte ich in der Regel irgendeinen Mailblurb, ja, mit zerstörten Umlauten und mit irgendwie 1000 eingefügten...
Und einem Ausschnitt aus dem SMTP-Protokoll.
Ja, und alles in Englisch und irgendwie völlig unklar, sodass mein Mailclient noch nicht mal weiß, worum es sich dabei handelt. Also für ihn ist so ein technischer Report, der im Prinzip ein konnte nicht zugestellt werden ist. Also sozusagen etwas, wo hier, wenn ich einen Brief verschicke mit der Post, und der konnte nicht zugestellt werden, da gibt es dann zumindest so einen halbwegs amtlichen Stempel, aus dem ich sofort ersehen kann, ah, alles klar, Metadata konnte nicht zugestellt werden. Ich kriege nicht einen normalen, an mich adressierten Brief, den ich dann öffne, und dann besteht zur Hälfte aus etwas, was ich mal verschickt habe, plus noch irgendwas anderem.
Kryptischen, in der Regel.
Ja, ich meine, da frage ich mich, warum? Also warum, das Mailsystem gibt es jetzt seit 20 Jahren, warum gibt es da einfach keinerlei, oder gibt es was? Ich weiß nicht.
Und ich kann die Frage, warum auch nicht beantworten.
Nee, keine Ahnung, also es ist halt einfach...
Das ist doch wirklich zum Mäusemelken.
Oder es ist halt historisch gewachsen, gehört halt...
Ja gut, aber man könnte doch trotzdem jetzt mal losziehen und einfach mal irgendwas definieren. Ich meine, wenn es da so ein klares...
Wer soll das dann übernehmen? Also ich meine, es gibt halt so viele Überlegungen.
Also man könnte eine WFC zu Bones-Messages machen.
Ja gut, aber die muss dann auch wiederum implementiert werden.
Ja, aber man könnte da was Signiertes verschicken, man könnte wirklich sagen, hier, das ist von... Das könnte man irgendwie überprüfen. Das heißt, man wüsste auch, dass von Domain, Tra-la-la, jetzt hier ein Fehlerbericht kommt und nicht irgendeine Spam-Battel gereicht wurde.
Halt irgendwas, was der Client interpretieren kann, sodass er dann nämlich auch in der Sprache des Users fest ihm dem User sagen kann, okay, da ist was gekommen und du wirst es nicht lesen können, aber ich kann es lesen und ich kann dir sagen, was es bedeutet in deiner Sprache.
Genau, also wenn da so was kommt, was irgendwie mit Verschlüsselung und mit Signaturen, schon mal, ah, ich weiß, das ist wirklich von dieser Domain, weil es irgendwie ein Zertifikat von Tralala und so weiter ist, Veri-Sign unterschrieben und so weiter. Ich weiß, das kommt wirklich von dieser Domain. Und dann steht da drin, wirklich wohl definiert, genau, hübsch in XML, das eigentliche Problem. Und dann kann mein Mailclient mir das eben auch in meiner Sprache, so wie mein Mailclient der Meinung ist, mir das jetzt näherbringen zu müssen, so hier setze ich mal hin, irgendwie, sei nicht schockiert.
Du hast da mal eine Mail geschickt.
Ja, das begreife ich einfach nicht. Und das begreife ich vor allem auch deshalb nicht, weil sich dieses ganze E-Mail-System in einem totalen Tohuwabuhu befindet, meiner Meinung nach. Also es ist einfach schlimm. Ich meine, ich bekomme immer noch, und ich habe schon ein ziemlich hochgerüstetes Mail-Setup für den durchschnittlichen Internetanwender gesehen, wo schon Leute, die das irgendwie mehr als zehn Jahre beobachten, Hand anlegen, und ich kriege halt trotzdem noch den ganzen Tag irgendwie schlimmes Zeug.
Ja, na gut. Also Spam ist sicherlich halt irgendwie das Problem, wobei man sagen muss, dass...
Aber es ist nicht nur Spam. Es ist auch einfach, selbst wenn es gar keinen Spam gäbe, benimmt sich dieses Mail-System unanständig. Es schickt mir einfach unanständige E-Mails. Also allein diese Formatierungen finde ich eine Frechheit. Findest du das nicht auch?
In den Bounces meinst du?
Ja, zum Beispiel.
Also immer noch besser zu lesen als E-Mails von eBay zum Beispiel. Also mit denen komme ich überhaupt nicht klar.
Ja, aber HTML-E-Mails, man kann sie mögen oder nicht, sogar die haben ja dann teilweise schon mehr Ästhetik als das, was man so normalerweise um die Ohren geschmissen bekommt.
Also es gibt tatsächlich keinen Standard, dass sie das Bounce verfahren.
Gut, habe ich also Recht. Schade. Also vielleicht kennen wir es ja auch nur nicht, aber es benutzt doch keiner in Zweifel.
Ich sehe auch immer lustige deutsche und englische Punkte, Fehlermelden.
Ich hoffe und ich rechne auch damit, dass in dem Blog-Eintrag zu dieser Sendung viele Kommentare eingehen werden. Fühlt euch schon mal aufgefordert, da was zu machen. Wo wir jetzt gerade so mit diesem Annehmen und so weiter sind und eigentlich auch schon so ein bisschen dieses Spam-Thema haben, wir können aber auch noch beliebig wechseln und müssen das auch nochmal machen. Da gibt es auch noch dieses TarPit-Verfahren, dass man Mails, also in dem Moment, wo man weiß, da kommt jetzt so Spam, also man weiß, da ist jetzt so ein Bösewicht, dass man dann besonders langsam macht. Verwendet ihr das?
Ich verwende das nicht, aber ich glaube, ich bin schon mal Opfer geworden von so was.
Nein, also ich verwende das auch. Also wenn ich merke, da stimmt was nicht, dann schicke ich die finale Ablehnung dafür innerhalb des SMTP-Protokolls. Dann auch erst, keine Ahnung.
Kurz vor dem Timeout.
Ja, genau.
Oder jedes Zeichen einzeln.
So eine halbe Minute oder was? Ja, sowas. Was halt blöderweise der Fall ist in dem Moment, ist, dass der...
Ist deine Verbindung, ist für dich?
Meine Verbindung ist nämlich auch. Also was ich gerne hätte, was es leider nicht gibt... Was ist denn für ein... Also ich meine, ich blockiere auch eine eigene Ressource dafür.
Ja, ein Port. Oder auch ein Prozess im Zweifel oder ein Thread zumindest.
Was auch immer. Also auf jeden Fall Dinge. Und was ich gerne hätte, was es glaube ich aber nicht gibt, auch dazu bitte, Einsendung, falls das nicht...
Dass es am Kernel abgelegt wird und der das macht.
Richtig, nein, genau. Also ich möchte eigentlich die Verbindung schließen, aber beim Verbindungsbeenden ein Flag setzen und sagen, das Reset-Paket schick mal nicht.
Genau.
Sondern kann ich bei mir alles schön zumachen irgendwie, mein ganzes Schweißerdienst.
Also das Reset-Paket ist auf TCP-Ebene das letzte Paket, was die TCP-Verbindung abrichtet.
Was der gegenüberliegenden Seite sagt, irgendwie die Verbindungsgrade geschlossen worden. Und es wäre eigentlich ganz schick, wenn man quasi dieses Reset-Paket für solche Verbindungen ignorieren, also gar nicht erst rausschicken könnte.
Aber trotzdem alle Ressourcen freigegeben.
Das gibt es bestimmt. Wahrscheinlich. Aber der POSIX-Standard, ich müsste mich sehr täuschen, irgendwie der POSIX-Standard definiert das nicht. Wenn ich da falsch liege, dann wäre mir das sogar recht.
Zumal sich da die Spammer relativ einfach gegen wehren können, weil da haben sie ja ihre Antwort schon.
Die wissen ja nicht, dass nichts mehr kommt. Die müssen auf jeden Fall zwei Minuten warten, oder was auch immer der TCP-Timeout ist.
Achso, du schickst auch dann keinen, habe ich nicht angenommen. Du sagst einfach, pff, egal.
Ist weg.
Aber du schließt die Verbindung nicht auf eine Art und Weise, dass sie dann auch wirklich technisch beendet ist und der weiß, dass da nichts mehr kommt.
Das heißt, auf der anderen Seite gibt es dann das Timeout-Problem. Es ist natürlich hässlich, aber ich meine, wir befinden uns ja im Krieg, was soll das?
Kollateralschäden, auch in beide Richtungen, verstehe. Du warst ja eh gerade dabei, dass du mal aufgezählt hast, welche Maßnahmen du jetzt in deinem Mail-Setup ergriffen hast, um sozusagen die Wahrscheinlichkeit von Spam einzudämmen. Genau.
Erst mal generell nicht annehmen.
Nicht annehmen, lange warten, bis man sagt, dass man es nicht annimmt, wenn man es überhaupt sagt?
Na ja, also die Frage ist halt, was führt dazu, die Mail nicht anzunehmen, ne? Also das ist halt schon ein Paket. Ja, also klar, die Mail nicht anzunehmen, diese Entscheidung basiert halt auf ganz vielen Kriterien, zumindest in meinem Setup. Und da spielen zum Beispiel so Dinge eine Rolle, wie ich lasse zum Beispiel auch keine anfragenden Hosts mehr zu, die keine rückwärts auflösbare Adresse haben.
Finde ich auch übertrieben, aber okay.
Ich schmeiße einfach, ne, weiß ich nicht. Also ich hab das eine Weile lang beobachtet und diese Regel trifft zu 100% die Richtigen bei mir.
Also bei mir nicht zu 100%.
Aber wer trifft es denn, der nicht die Richtige ist?
Na, derjenige, der sein Server nicht richtig im DNS konfiguriert hat. Also PTR sind halt Reverse Records, also dass es zu einer IP-Adresse auch einen Namen gibt. Und du überprüfst wahrscheinlich nicht nur, ob es einen Namen gibt, sondern ob es in beide Richtungen passt.
Ich glaube, da möchtest du jetzt nachgucken. Aber ich glaube, das wiederum hat zu viel Probleme gemacht.
Zu viel Kollateralschäden.
Zu viel Kollateralschäden, ja.
Okay, das kann man auch machen. Also man guckt sozusagen, da kommt ja jemand an und macht eine Verbindung zu einem auf und dann hat man nur die IP-Adresse. Jetzt guckt man zu dieser IP-Adresse nach dem Namen, also nach dem PTR-Record im DNS, schickt dann einen Namen und kann dann zu dem Namen noch mal nach der IP-Adresse fragen. Dann könnte man auch noch, was Daniel jetzt nicht tut, aber was man auch noch machen könnte, ist, wenn die Namen dann nicht übereinstimmen, nein, wenn zu dem Namen dann nicht die Adresse kommt, von derjenige...
Okay, aber was sagt denn das aus, wenn der eine Name und der andere Namen nicht übereinstimmen?
Dass er seinen Rechner eingetragen hat im DNS. Dass er sein DNS konfiguriert hat. Oder dass er... Ja, dass er sein DNS konfiguriert hat, das ist ein schlecht konfigurierter Name. Also DSL-Kunden haben doch auch alle einen Reversed Lookup.
Haben sie gelegentlich?
In der Regel doch sogar. Haben nicht inzwischen alle einen Reversed Lookup automatisch?
Ich kriege ziemlich viele Spam-Anfragen von IP-Adressen, die keine DNS-Entsprechung haben. Gibt es ganz viele bei mir. Aber wie auch immer, muss man sich anschauen. Fakt scheint für mich zu sein, dass diese Administratoren, die sich ernsthaft mit ihrem Mailset auseinandersetzen und wollen, dass es ordentlich funktioniert, auch dafür sorgen, dass entsprechende DNS-Einträge richtig gesetzt sind, dass sich diese Server korrekt verhalten usw. Und Spammer kamen daher auf keinen Einfluss. Deswegen trifft es in dem Fall zu fast 100% die richtigen.
Also zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich das nicht machen wollte, heute würde ich es vielleicht auch anders einschätzen, war es so, dass es bei Providern unter Umständen nicht mal so ohne Weiteres möglich war, ein Reverse-Mapping zu kriegen. Also wenn man sozusagen einen Mietrechner hat, das gibt es heute, die haben, glaube ich, denke ich mal, immer wenn man einen Mietrechner hat, kann man in einem Web-Interface eintragen, was für ein Reverse-Lookup man haben will. Weil es nämlich so ist, dass man ja die Hoheit über den eigenen DNS-Server gilt nur für die eigene Domain, aber nicht für die eigene IP-Adresse, sondern für die IP-Adresse ist in der Regel der Provider zuständig, oder der ISP, oder wie man die jetzt auch immer nennt, der Hoster. Deshalb war das früher schon ein Problem, das Reverse-Mapping hinzukriegen, unter Umständen. Also bei manchen Providern.
Ist es aber nicht mehr, weil es ist ja auch für so ganz einfache Sachen wie SSH eigentlich auch schon ein Thema. Die Reverse-Geschichte. Wird das nicht unter bestimmten Bedingungen bei SSH auch geprüft?
Ja, wenn der so konfiguriert ist, dass er das...
Ja, kann man machen.
Na, es gibt noch mehr Maßnahmen. Es gibt noch Grey-Listing.
Ja, das setze ich auch ein.
Grey-Listing heißt, da kommt einer, und den hat man noch nie vorher gesehen. Und dann sagt man dem, ah, mir geht es gar nicht so gut.
Also die E-Mail-Adresse, die Absender-E-Mail-Adresse.
Nee, die Absender-IP-Adresse. In der Regel auf die IP-Adresse. Man kann es auch noch kombinieren mit Absender-E-Mail-Adresse und auch noch mit Ziel-E-Mail-Adresse. Das wäre dann erweitert, aber machen wir den einfachen Fall zuerst. Die IP-Adresse ist noch nie da gewesen. Und dann sagt man erst mal, mir geht es gerade nicht so gut, komm mal später wieder.
Wie sagt man das dann?
Das sind die Errorcodes, die mit 4 beginnen. 2 bedeutet, ist in Ordnung, 2xx.
Alles gut, weitermachen.
Der 4xx-Block ist Temporary Failure. Das sind so Dinge wie... Datalink, Zugriff, Verpeilung. Behalten mal lieber die Mail. An der Stelle sieht man auch, dass das gesamte System auch wirklich so ausgelegt wurde. SMTP kommt damit eigentlich ganz wunderbar klar. Wenn mal irgendwo ein Mail-Server nicht erreichbar ist, dann bleibt die Mail eben bei dem anderen Server in der Queue. Und sagt, okay, kein Problem. Ich probiere das dann irgendwie in einem bestimmten Intervall nochmal.
Das sind die Atombombe. Ja, eine vorübergehende Atombomb-Explosion verhindert die Annahme dieser E-Mail.
Bitte probieren Sie es später noch ein Mal. Ein verdammt langer Timer-Ort bis zum Endmesser.
Zum Grey Listing zurück. Also ich sage dem dann, der war noch nie hier, also schicke ich dem Temporary Failure. So, dann kommt er nach einer Sekunde wieder, dann sage ich ihm nochmal Temporary Failure, weil dann glaube ich, der ist ein bisschen doof und bestimmt ein Spammer. Wenn er dann aber in 10 Minuten wiederkommt oder wie auch immer ich das konfiguriere, in 20 Minuten oder in einer Stunde, wenn er dann wiederkommt und vorher nicht wiedergekommen ist, dann sage ich ihm, okay, deine Mail leite ich jetzt weiter. Du scheinst ein Vernünftiger im TA zu sein und nicht ein Spammer, weil also, manchmal ist es jetzt auch schon anders.
Das heißt, das ist auch so ein bisschen wie dieses Tar-Pitting, dass man halt so eine Verzögerung erzeugt, von der man ausgeht, dass die Spammer das nicht mögen.
Genau, und dann merkt man sich die Adresse für 24 Stunden oder 48 Stunden oder eine Woche oder einen Monat und solange darf der halt immer sofort einliefern und wird nicht erstmal zurückgewiesen, weil diese Zurückweisung natürlich auch das ein bisschen hemmt, die Geschwindigkeit, mit der die E-Mails dann ausgeliefert werden.
Man muss ja auch nochmal festhalten, die meisten MTAs, die meisten Mailserver, die halt Mails verschicken, ändern ja ihre IP-Adresse eigentlich auch. Nicht? Nicht.
Nicht, na natürlich nicht.
Mal vielleicht, aber eben nicht.
Ja, aber es ist halt tatsächlich ein Hack, der auch nur bedingt funktioniert oder hat in der Vergangenheit bis vor, ich schreibe mal so gefühlt, bis vor einem halben, dreiviertel oder einem ganzen Jahr irgendwie hat er ganz gut gegriffen.
Also es reduziert immer noch kräftig. Aber nicht mehr so 90 oder 100 Prozent, sondern eben nur noch 30 Prozent.
Was einfach daran liegt, dass mittlerweile die Spammer halt auch dazugelernt haben und die sind jetzt eben auch in der Lage. Ja genau, also die versuchen es halt einfach nochmal. Wenn sie einen Temporary-Failer kriegen, dann versuchen sie es einfach irgendwie, sie versuchen es einfach ständig und irgendwann kommen sie dann halt durch.
Also sie machen schon die Zeit auch größer, nach der sie es wieder versuchen, bis es halt irgendwann mal klappt.
Also sie haben das Queuing gelernt und das war von Anfang an klar. Bei diesem Quellessen, das kann nur so lange funktionieren, wie die Spammer zu blöd zum Queuen sind. Und das ist halt mittlerweile nicht mehr so.
Aber es reduziert die Last schon doch erheblich. Also man kann damit eine Prozessorlastreduzierung hinkriegen.
Also ein weiteres Problem am Greylisting ist halt auch, dass Mailprovider, wie ich glaube Yahoo war es, die interpretieren Soft-Failures als Hard-Failures und bouncing direkt. Also wenn dir jemand von Yahoo eine Nachricht schickt und du sagst einfach, ist gerade ein temporäres Problem, dann sagt Yahoo, ach so ein Problem, dann werde ich gleich mal die Mail zurücknehmen. Dann haben wir halt einfach das Protokoll nicht richtig implementiert an der Stelle.
Ich musste ein paar selber whitelisten, stimmt's?
Richtig, deswegen gibt es dann wieder Whitelists für bestimmte Maßnahmen und das muss man halt auch irgendwie pflegen. Also es ist schon nervig.
Gibt es denn dafür dann gute Quellen? Whitelists?
Gibt es, ja.
Wobei ich habe es bemerkt, wenn irgendeiner meiner User seine Mail nicht bekommen hat. Also ich habe mich nicht umgekümmert, dann auch whitelisten.
Also jetzt ordnet sich auch dieser Begriff greatlisting ganz gut ein. Eigentlich gibt es Blacklisting und whitelisting. Das heißt, whitelisting ist ein Server, der steht auf der weißen Liste, der darf irgendwie immer, der ist gut, weil man weiß einfach, der verschickt, naja, keinen oder...
Oder kann wenigstens nichts dafür, wenn es jemand verschickt.
Genau.
Der ist nicht schuld.
Blacklisting entsprechend sperrt halt ein. Und das ist ja häufig ein Problem.
Sind wir jetzt bei den RBLs schon?
Könnte man an der Stelle erwähnen. Also eine Geschichte, die ich noch konfiguriert habe in dem Zusammenhang ist, für manche, nicht alle, ich sag auch gleich warum, Domains, mache ich einen Rückwärtscheck. Also wenn wir wieder das Beispiel nehmen, da kommt Tim mit seinem tim.mydomain.de an und will an danielexample.com eine Mail abliefern. Dann sagt mein Mailserver, warte mal, wer sagst du, bist du tim.mydomain.de? Bleib mal kurz dran, halte mal kurz die Verbindung. Und ich frage rückwärts beim eingetragenen MX-Record von mydomain.de nach, wie sieht es denn aus? Kennst du einen tim.mydomain.de? Würdest du eine Mail an den zustellen? Dann sagt der, nö, kenn ich nicht. Irgendwie dann sag ich dem anderen, der andere noch offenen Verbindung so, ich lehne deine Mail ab, weil der MX-Record von mydomain.de hat nämlich gerade gesagt, tim.mydomain.de gibt es nicht, also geh weg.
Aber die Spammer verwenden auch häufig gültige E-Mail-Adressen.
Gut, in dem Fall funktioniert es dann nicht. Das ist richtig, klar.
Das sind alles nur kleine Bausteine, die sozusagen dazu beitragen.
Ja, ja, man muss an vier Fronten kämpfen.
Warum machst du das nicht für alle?
Weil manche, manche, oder ich machs nicht für alle, weil manche E-Mail-Provider sowieso zu jeder Adresse Ja sagen, wie zum Beispiel Google Mail. Und andere reagieren auch irgendwie gereizt darauf, wenn du versuchst irgendwie E-Mails.
Sie anzusprechen, wenn sie dir was ausliefern. Das kann auch zu einer Loop werden.
Das hatte ich tatsächlich auch schon, weil die dann das gleiche wieder bei mir versuchen. Deswegen muss man ein bisschen aufpassen, mit wem man das treibt. Da gibt es ganz gut gepflegte Listen im Internet, die alle diese Adressen beinhalten, bei denen das ganz wunderbar funktioniert und damit...
Wie heißt das?
Das nennt sich, ich könnte dir jetzt nur sagen, die Postfix-Konfiguration.
Okay, Rückruf kann man es nennen.
Ja, ich suche das nochmal raus.
Du schickst ja so einen Privatdetektiv los, der mal guckt, ob der auch wirklich... Ob das nicht so eine Briefkastenfirma ist. So, aber was ist denn jetzt hier mit diesen Blacklists? Die Listen von IP-Adressen oder von Domainnamen, ich weiß gar nicht, was wird da üblicherweise geführt. IP-Adressen wahrscheinlich.
Es gibt eine ganze Menge. Es gibt die IP-Adresse des anfragenden Hosts. Es gibt Sender-Adressen als Blacklist.
Also kann man in seinem MTA machen.
Richtig, es gibt halt solche Lists. Es gibt leider immer weniger von diesen Blacklists, weil viele einfach die Flügel strecken, weil die Request zu viele sind.
Also diese RBLs funktionieren ja auch über DNS.
Was heißt denn das RBL?
Da konfiguriert man quasi eine Domain in seinem. Also ein RBL-SMTP. Nee, doch. Also da definiert man eine Domain. Zum Beispiel spamcorp.com ist glaube ich eine von denen. Und da kommt dann sozusagen wieder eine IP-Adresse an und man guckt sich die IP-Adresse an und fragt dann im DNS von spamcorp, ob es da einen Eintrag gibt für diese IP-Adresse. Und wenn es den gibt, dann weiß man, der ist geblacklistet von spamcorp. Spamhaus, spam irgendwas. Es gibt viele. Ja, da gibt es viele, genau. Und die haben halt alle verschiedene Policies. Also die einen sagen, wir gucken uns die DSL IP-Ranges an und nehmen die einfach mal pauschal auf in unsere Blacklist. Oder wir nehmen Leute auf die Bounces verschicken.
Open Relays natürlich.
Open Relays natürlich, die nehmen sie alle auf. Also die testen, ob sie eine Mail über einen Server an sich selbst verschicken können. Und wenn das geht, dann wissen sie, das ist ein Open Relay und der kommt dann erstmal in diese RBLs.
Es gibt solche, die zum Beispiel keine Post für Abuse oder Postmaster annehmen. Die sind auch gepflegt. Kann man sagen, du schickst von einer Domain, die sind so ignorant, deswegen heißt die Liste auch rfcignorant.org, dass wir nicht mit dir reden. Also Leute, die an Abuse keine Mail annehmen, mit denen reden wir nicht. Egal, was da vor dem Ad-Zeichen steht, das ist eigentlich total wurscht.
Allwissende Müllhalde leitet RBL mittlerweile auf DNS-BL, DNS-Blacklist oder auch Blackhole-Liste um.
Und dann, was gibt es da noch? Dann gibt es da noch Bayes-Filter serverseitig.
Genau, also wenn es dann mal so weit ist, dass die Mail wirklich angenommen wurde, wozu noch übrigens führen kann, das kann auch verhindert werden durch ein System, das wir auch unbedingt ansprechen sollten, das nennt sich SPF. Das ist das Center Policy Framework. Etwas umstritten, was die so treiben, aber erwähnen sollte man es auf jeden Fall trotzdem. SPF funktioniert folgendermaßen, man trägt in seiner Domain ein mit einem TXT-Rekord, dass man die Hosts, von denen E-Mails mit dieser Absenderadresse kommen, einschränkt. Man sagt also, mail, die von example.com kommt, die kommt eigentlich nur von meinem Mx-Rekord.
postman.example.com ist der einzige Rechner, der Mails verschicken darf, und wenn von irgendjemand anders was kommt, der nicht er ist, dann darf das überhaupt nicht angenommen werden. Ich kenne das auch und ich erinnere mich sogar noch an eine alte Chaosradio-Sendung, wo wir uns über Spam unterhalten haben, und da war das gerade so, das heißt, Chick auf der Straße. Warum ist das so im Stritten?
Naja, es gibt...
Weil eigentlich ist es doch...
Hört sich erstmal gut an.
Hört sich das erstmal gut an, vor allem, man macht ja gar keine Maßnahmen. Man sagt ja nur, ich verschicke Mail nur von hier. Punkt.
Genau, man sagt dann noch irgendwie in... Also, entsprechend kodiert in diesem TXT-Rekord, dass man möchte, dass alle andere... Also, dass Mail, die von woanders kommt, dann wirklich auch hart rejected wird. Das heißt glaube ich, minus all oder so was. Das bedeutet, dass alle anderen, die nicht gewaltlistet sind in diesem TXT-Rekord, einfach einen harten Fehler kriegen. Das Problem an der Sache ist, dass E-Mail-Forwarding im Internet leider immer noch eine Rolle spielt. Also, wenn ein MTA, ein Mailserver, Mail annimmt und dann feststellt, dass dieser User hier gar nicht lokal ist, sondern mittlerweile umgezogen ist auf einen anderen Rechner, dann geht er eben her und verschickt mit derselben Absenderadresse an einen anderen User diese Mail. Wenn der dann, der zweite MTA dahinter, feststellt, wenn der SPF-Check macht, stellt er fest, die Mail kommt eigentlich von adxhabit.com, aber sie kommt von der IP-Adresse eines ganz anderen Servers, dann lehnt der die Mail ab, obwohl sie eigentlich zugestellt werden müsste. Das ist halt, das heißt, das bricht dann.
Beim Empfänger muss auch noch alles richtig konfiguriert sein, wenn er ein Forwarding macht.
Richtig, dann musst du den Forwardenden MTA entsprechend weitlisten in deinem TXT-Rekord für SPR.
Das müsste dann der machen, der ihn empfängt.
Warum gibt es das, und wenn nicht, warum nicht, müsste es dann nicht im SMTP so sein. Ich schicke jetzt an lalala.timatxample.com, soll die Mail gehen. In dem normalen Forwarding-Fall wird die Mail angenommen und dann wird sie weitergeleitet. Warum nicht gleich schon auf der Ebene sagen, ist umgezogen, bitte diese E-Mail-Adresse verwenden?
Das ist halt nicht vorgesehen im SMTP.
Ist es nicht? Ich bin mir gerade auch unsicher. Aber es gibt keinen so einen Redirect, gibt es nicht.
Das wird angenommen und wieder losgeschickt. Aber beim Wieder-Los-Schicken könnte man, es gibt ja verschiedene From- und To-Adressen in so einer Mail.
Genau, das muss man an der Stelle auch unbedingt erwähnen, dass da auf gar keinen Fall unterschlagen wird.
Also es gibt sozusagen das SMTP-To und das SMTP-From und dann in der Mail steht auch nochmal ein From und ein To drin. Und das sind unter Umständen unterschiedliche Adressen. Also es gibt einmal das Envelope-From und Envelope-To, hieß es früher, also das, was in der SMTP-Verbindung ausgehandelt wird oder ausgesprochen wird. Und dann gibt es halt in der Mail, das, was man klassischerweise in seinem E-Mail-Klient sieht, gibt es halt auch noch ein From und To.
In den Mail-Headern entsprechend kodiert.
Genau. Und ich habe meinen Mail-Server halt so konfiguriert, dass ich das Envelope-From auch noch sehe. Ne, das Envelope-To vor allen Dingen auch. Also an wen die Mail eigentlich ging auf SMTP-Ebene, ist auch noch interessant.
Kann man das nochmal kurz ein bisschen plastischer darstellen? Also Envelope bemüht sich ja sozusagen schon dieser Assoziation mit einem Briefumschlag. Also man hat die eigentliche Mail, sprich der eigentliche Brief, das ist in der Vierblatt, wo die Post drauf ist, und da steht drauf...
An und von?
An Dirk. So, dann nehme ich aber diesen Brief und tue ihn einen Umschlag, und da schreibe ich auch drauf an Dirk. Und nur das, was auf dem Umschlag steht, ist relevant für die Weiterleitung des Briefs.
Ja, es sei denn, kennst du ein Setup, Daniel, wo die Leute auch in den From-Header gucken und in den To-Header, um Spam-Detection oder sowas zu machen? Das passiert eigentlich nicht, oder?
Doch, das mache ich schon auch.
Also nicht nur Envelope From und Envelope To, sondern auch...
Auch in den Headers, ja. Also Postrix kann auch ganz wunderbar in den Headers buchen, auch nach Subjects und so weiter.
Aber jetzt gibt es ja sozusagen diese Möglichkeit... Also ich habe das ja zum Beispiel auch in meinem Mailclient mit drin. Das ist zwar eins dieser Features, die man bei Mailclients meistens dann noch mal, also die nicht alle haben. Und selbst die, die es haben, da muss man es manchmal noch mal explizit einschalten, ist jetzt zum Beispiel bei MailApp auf dem Maxo. Wenn ich eine Mail kriege und was weiß ich, mir schickt jemand direkt eine Mail an mich, von der ich aber eigentlich möchte, dass sie an einen Sammel-Account geht. Bestes Beispiel ist so Blinkenlights. Und jemand schreibt mich direkt an wegen Blinkenlights. Und möchte aber, dass das irgendwie an Contact-Ed Blinkenlights geht. Ich möchte aber jetzt nicht die Mail vorworten, weil dann wäre sie ja von mir. Also mache ich ein Re-Direct. Und dann kommt diese Mail tatsächlich dann an den anderen Account an, so als wäre sie da sowieso schon von Anfang an hingeschickt worden. Ist das das, was mit diesem Envelope gemacht wird?
Ich schätze mal, im Envelope From steht dann aber trotzdem deine Adresse. Nur im Mail From steht die. Die Mail selbst wird nicht verändert, aber der Envelope wird schon modifiziert. Sonst gäbe es bestimmt Probleme.
Sonst würde das wiederum bei SPF Probleme auslösen.
Auch das ist sozusagen schwierig.
Genau, SPF guckt auf den Envelope From.
Ja, weil ich ja dann sozusagen für jemand anderen eine Mail nochmal neu einliefere und auch an der Stelle würde es brechen mit SPF.
Richtig.
Das heißt, wenn mein Mail-Server einen SPF-Check machen würde, dann könnte ich dieses Riederrecht schon gar nicht mehr benutzen?
Das ist jetzt eben die Frage, wie dein Mail-Line das genau macht. Wahrscheinlich hat Dirk recht.
Das würde schon gehen, weil im Envelope-To... Nee, wenn im Envelope-From deine Adresse steht und nicht die von dem ursprünglichen Sender, dann ist alles in Ordnung.
Genau.
Dann wird SPF denken, dass die Mail von dir kommt oder die kommt von deinem Server.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum SPF im Zusammenhang mit Mailing-Listen zum Beispiel kein Problem darstellt. Zumindest mit Mailing-Listen, die sauber konfiguriert sind. Wenn man sich die Mail genau anschaut. Übrigens, jeder Mail-Klein bietet, zumindest jeder mir bekannte Mail-Klein, die Möglichkeit, sich auch wirklich die Headers mal anzuschauen. Die in so einer... Ja, genau, die...
Wer das noch nicht gemacht hat, das sollte man sich auf jeden Fall mal geben.
Genau, weil man nämlich dabei auch ganz gut sieht, über welche Hops die Mail so gegangen ist. Das haben wir bisher auch noch gar nicht erwähnt.
Ja, das ist interessant. Also jede Mail, wenn sie einmal weitergeleitet wird, wird ja tatsächlich modifiziert. Das heißt, da kommen laufenden Meter neue Header hinzu. Unter anderem halt so ein Poststempel. Diese Mail ist hier eingegangen am Um, wurde angenommen von und weitergeleitet an...
Da steht sogar die TLS-Geschichte in der Regel drin. Also wenn es über TLS gekommen ist, steht in der Receive-Zeile auch drin, dass es über TLS angenommen wurde. Das ist auch interessant zu sehen.
Das kann ja jeder reinschreiben.
Stimmt, das könnte jemand später einer der weiteren Hosts reingeschrieben haben. Muss nicht so sein, aber es ist...
Es ist nicht wirklich ein Beweis, es ist eher so ein Indiz.
Aber bei den Headern, genau, was haben wir denn da so für Header?
Also Header haben wir eine ganze Menge. Ach, du hast auch ein Original Tool.
Genau, das ist das Envelope From.
Also was wir zum nächsten Mal haben, sind die Header, die der Mail-Client, der MUA erzeugt hat. Das sind so Dinge wie...
Also vielleicht sollten wir nochmal kurz festhalten für die Leute, die jetzt wirklich bisher durchgehalten haben, aber trotzdem dem Thema noch neu sind. Also eine Mail besteht aus Header und Body. Body ist das, die eigentliche Mail, die man schreibt. Header ist so, von dem man immer so ein bisschen was sieht, nämlich das geht an und ist von und bitte Antworten an und so weiter.
Subject natürlich, das ist auch Teil der Header-Infangenzahl.
Genau, auch genau das. Und wenn man aber dann in seinem Mail-Client mal sagt, ach, jetzt zeig mir mal alle Header, dann wird man auf einmal erschlagen von, ja, da sind da nicht nur vier oder fünf Zahlen, die man normalerweise angezeigt bekommt, sondern das kann richtig lang werden.
Genau, weil jeder Mail-Server, der in der Kette diese Mail dann einmal bekommt und angenommen hat und weitergeleitet hat, seine eigene Received-Seite drüber setzt. Oder hängt sie oben an, weiß ich, deswegen ist der erste Mail-Server in der Kette, der die Mail jemals gesehen hat, der unterste Eintrag. Und dann geht es eben weiter, indem jeder Mail-Server seinen Stempeln drüber schreibt.
Empfang von Tralala-Adresse, IP-Adresse und die Software, die das behandelt hat, mit welchem Protokoll.
Und das Office hat es mir mit TLS geschickt. Das Office vom CCC. Hier TLS und da TLS.
Genau, das sieht man da. Deswegen auch ganz interessant zu sehen, wie viel verschlüsselte Kommunikation dann doch schon am Start ist.
Und da steht auch der Helostream gleich mit drin.
Von TLS sehe ich hier gar nichts, aber ESMTP kommt zum Einsatz. Das heißt aber noch nicht, dass es verschlüsselt wurde.
Nein, nein, gar nichts.
Und diese ID, die da noch angezeigt wird?
Na das ist...
With ESMTP ID und dann so ein Hextring.
Na das ist sozusagen der Stempel, der Stempel, den der Mail-Server, der Mail aufdrückt und sagt, ich weise dir eine interne QID zu und bei mir bist du ab sofort bekannt unter der ID-Nummer sowieso.
So findet man den dann auch in den Log-Feld wieder.
Genau, also wenn die Mail dann irgendwann fehlt oder sowas, dann kann man sagen, naja, bei mir ist die Mail rausgegangen, mein Mail-Server hat sie deinem geschickt und dein Mail-Server hat gesagt, alles klar, ich habe sie gequeued unter der ID sowieso. Und wenn man hinterher dann also nachforschen muss, wo denn die Mail geblieben ist, kann man mit dieser ID dann eben in den Log-Felds des anderen sowas mal gucken, was dann eigentlich passiert ist.
Okay, wir müssen jetzt auch nicht hier durch jedes Detail durchgehen, aber diese Receive-Zahlen sind auf jeden Fall sehr aussagekräftig. Ah ja, jetzt habe ich hier auch mal was gefunden mit TLSV1, mit Cypher, Tralala, Schnickes, also mit Krypto und Bitlänger und Schlüssellänger und kein Zertifikat wurde verwendet und so weiter.
Genau.
Wir wollten jetzt auf diese Envelope-Geschichte mit dem Tour und dem Fromm und überhaupt zu sprechen drauf.
Ja, die stehen da natürlich nicht drauf.
Genau, also wenn man mal Mail aufmacht, die an eine Mailing-Liste ging zum Beispiel, weil der wahrscheinlich auch...
Wir müssen auch noch über Mailing-Listen reden.
Ja, wir müssen auch über Mailing-Listen reden. Da gucken wir jetzt langsam hin, glaube ich.
Genau, also ich habe hier zum Beispiel jetzt gerade eine Mail vor mir. Da wird deutlich in den entsprechenden Received-Zeilen, die dazugekommen sind, dass die Envelope-From-Adresse umgeschrieben wird. Also diese Mail, die ich hier habe, die kam ursprünglich von jemandem, der sie an eine Mailing-Liste geschickt hat. Und diese Mailing-Listen-Server findet raus, dass ich da auch subscribt bin und schickt mir eine Mail wiederum, die aber dann den Mailing-Listen-Namen Minus Bounces hat. Und das ist dann die, also es muss nicht Minus Bounces heißen, aber das ist in der Regel der gewählte Name dafür. Und nutzt diese dann als Envelope-Adresse. Das heißt bei mir, in meiner SMTP-Kommunikation, meines Servers, kommt diese Mail dann entsprechend mit diesem Bounces-Namen an. Nicht mehr mit dem Original Envelope From des ursprünglichen Senders.
Was ein ganz wichtiges Feature ist.
Genau, weil nämlich unter anderem, deswegen wurde das zwar nicht gemacht, aber unter anderem bewirkt das, dass SPF im Zusammenhang mit Mailing-Listen funktioniert.
Achso, bei mir ist das eher das Feature, dass wenn derjenige dann gar nicht mehr existiert, der da diese Mail gekriegt hat, dann bounce die nämlich an diese Adresse geschickterweise und bounce dann sozusagen in die Mailing-Listen-Software rein. Und die Mailing-Listen-Software kriegt, und nicht derjenige, der ursprünglich die Mail geschrieben hat, sondern die Mailing-Listen-Software kriegt dann den Bounce und bei EZMLM, also dem Mailing-Listen-Manager, den ich so verwende, der weiß dann auch gleich, dass er sich das dann mal merkt, dass der gebounced ist. Also er weiß auch, wer gebounced ist, weil nämlich in dem Envelope From auch noch die Adresse desjenigen, der es kriegt, drinsteht.
Ja, braucht die Software in meinem Fall jetzt hier nicht, aber kenn ich auch.
Und dann bounce das sozusagen nicht auf die Liste, also an alle, was das Schlimmste, der schlimmste anzunehmende Fall ist, und nicht an den Sender, weil denen interessiert es auch nicht, dass da einer nicht mehr auf der Liste drauf ist. Sondern es bounce an die Software, und die Software merkt sich das und probiert dann später nochmal demjenigen was zu schicken. Und wenn es halt zwölf Tage lang nicht geklappt hat, weil sein Mail-Account vielleicht gelöscht wurde oder so, oder voll gelaufen ist, dann kann die Software, die Mail-Dienst-Software, automatisch diesen Account auch austragen, und dann passiert auch nichts Schlimmes mehr.
Genau, also hinter dieser Minus-Bounces-Adresse oder wie auch immer sie dann halt heißt, steckt kein echter Empfänger, sondern eben ein Stück Skript.
Der Begriff Bounce taucht ja immer wieder auf. Wie würdet ihr den definieren im Kontext E-Mail?
Na, es gibt ja so Slang.
Bounce mir doch mal eine Mail. Das ist aber was anderes. Naja, aber es ist immer dasselbe Wort. Deswegen frage ich das jetzt gerade mal.
Der hüpft was zurück.
Also Bounce an sich ist eigentlich immer nur das Zurückspielen einer Mail gemeint. Also konnte die Zustelladresse nicht gefunden werden, Bounce gibt die Mail.
Abprallen ist glaube ich die Übersetzung in dem Fall.
Naja, klar.
Nur dass man auf Deutsch nicht sagt, prall mir mal die Mail ab.
Ja, also Bounce wird erzeugt von einem MTA unter anderem. Wenn der MTA feststellt, dass die Mail nicht zustellbar war. Also es kann einmal den Grund haben, weil der Server ebenso konfiguriert ist, dass er zu viel Mail annimmt und erst im Nachhinein feststellt, dass er die eigentlich gar nicht haben wollte und dann das Problem hat, die wieder loszuwerden. Oder kann auch ganz natürliche oder andere Gründe haben, wie zum Beispiel, du schickst eine Mail irgendwie an deinen Mailserver, der die entgegennimmt und weiß, ok, du darfst auch Mail verschicken, Mail relayen über mich, das dann eine Weile versucht, aber mein MX-Record, also mein Mailserver antwortet eben für, weiß ich nicht, sieben Tage am Stück nicht, weil er irgendwie ein Problem hat. Dann wird dein Mailserver eines Tages entscheiden, so jetzt ist das halt auch irgendwann mal gut, ich schicke die Mail jetzt mal zurück an denjenigen, der sie ursprünglich mal erzeugt hat, und du kriegst dann halt ein non-deliverable Notification.
Nicht zustellbar.
Richtig.
Manche schicken einem sogar noch Mail, dass sie sagen, dass es schon bisher ein paar Mal nicht geklappt hat, aber man soll mal die Pferde stillhalten, und es könnte ja noch klappen.
Das ist ja eine ganz interessante Information, dass diese Mail noch irgendwo unterwegs hängt und noch nicht angekommen ist.
Oder dass ich halt wieder dieses Gewäsch von diesem Mailserver selber interpretieren muss, und es nicht meine Software für mich tut.
Die sind aber ganz freundlich in der Regel.
Ja, aber diese Mails machen Angst. Also mir nicht mehr so sehr, aber ich würde sagen, der normale Mail-Benutzer fragt sich schon, was das soll. Und das auch total zurecht. Es ist wirklich sehr schade, dass es niemanden gibt, den man dafür mal schlagen könnte. Also dieses ganze Mailsystem ist mittlerweile so alt und hat sich so in der Breite entwickelt, dass ja noch nicht mal einer richtig schuld ist.
Ja, naja, auf der anderen Seite muss man...
Also beim Web, da kann man dann irgendwie auf Tim Berners-Lee einschlagen und so und auch jedes andere Projekt, da gibt es immer irgendeinen, wo man draufhauen kann. Nicht, dass es was bewirkt, aber man fühlt sich besser. Aber bei E-Mail gibt es noch nicht mal einen Kanal zum Abreagieren. Was soll man denn da machen?
Ja, naja, also auf der anderen Seite muss man sagen, dass sich dann doch die meisten Protokolle, die da zum Einsatz kommen, eben wirklich über Jahrzehnte gehalten haben und bisher ja auch noch keiner mit einer signifikant besseren Idee um die Ecke kam.
Ja, und normalerweise, das ist wirklich auch das, was mich so wundert. Ich meine, das Internet hat sich eigentlich an vielen Stellen immer so gezeigt, wenn es da ein akutes Problem gab, dann hat sich das auch irgendwie verbessert. Indem Verschlüsselungen hinzugefügt wurden und so weiter und so weiter. Auch im Web haben wir das schon häufiger auch gehabt und permanent auch diese Web-Development-Geschichte, die Probleme, die die Anwendungen im Browser haben. Also es gibt da einfach eine kontinuierliche Verbesserung. Nur bei E-Mail scheinen irgendwie alle komplett auf Durchzug zu schalten und niemand will sich das aufheisen.
Naja, die Frage ist halt schon, wie man dem konstruktiv begegnet. Also ich meine, was für Möglichkeiten hat man? Welche Ansätze gibt es dann irgendwie, das System besser zu machen, wenn man auf dem Spam absieht?
Na, man könnte ja so eine Y2K-Situation schaffen, dass man sagt, irgendwie ab 2010 kriegt einfach E-Mail nur noch ein System, das folgende Kriterien erfüllt. Und in 2015 werden die Kriterien verschärft und in 2020 ist richtig der Gartenhof vorbei.
Ja, aber es ist also nicht so klar, wie diese Kriterien aussehen sollten, um das System wirklich dann zu härten gegenüber Missbrauch, ja?
Auf jeder Melde wäre es schon mal ein Anfang.
Ja, aber also meines Erachtens ist das lange nicht das größte Problem. Also das größte Problem ist tatsächlich Spam.
Und den loszuwerden wird wirklich schwierig. Das kann man eigentlich nur machen, wenn ein E-Mail Geld kostet und das will ja nun wieder auch keiner.
Ja, also das ist eine Idee. Da kann man ein bisschen aufzählen, was es für Ideen gibt, die da so kursieren.
Oder halt Authentifizierung, also keine Anonymität mehr, nicht mal Pseudonymität. Aber es würde dann auch wieder kosten, weil die Infrastruktur für die Zertifikate muss ja auch erstmal da sein und finanziert werden. Also man kann das eigentlich nur durch Geld für E-Mail versenden.
Es gibt es esoterische Ansätze, die ich ganz interessant finde. Zum Beispiel Hashcash. Das ist eine ziemlich absurde Idee irgendwo, aber naja gut, sie könnte schon funktionieren. Die Idee ist folgende, dass man ein Header innerhalb der E-Mail erzeugt. Dieser Header enthält einen Zeitstempel und die Absender-Adresse und eine Zufallszahl. Dieser Header wird erzeugt durch diese Information und dann wird über dieses gesamte Ding eine Scha-Summe erzeugt. Wenn diese Scha-Summe nicht in den ersten 20 Bits Nullen enthält, dann wird die Zufallszahl um 1 erhöht und das Ganze nochmal probieren.
Man muss also richtig Rechenpower aufbringen, um das herzustellen.
Genau, das ist die Idee dahinter. Das dauert halt auf modernen...
Das ist nochmal für Dumme.
Du brauchst halt einen richtig fiesen Rechenprozess, um eine Mail zu erzeugen. Das kostet dich richtig Rechenzyklen.
Wurde das jetzt sichergestellt?
Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Ich habe irgendwie so einen Hasch.
Der sendende Server, nein, das sendende E-Mail-Programm geht her und erzeugt einen Hasch über deine E-Mail-Adresse, einen Zeitstempel und eine Zufallszahl. Wenn ein Hasch über diese Information 20 Bits Nullen ergibt an den ersten Stellen, dann gilt diese Unterschrift, dieser Header als valide. Und wenn nicht, dann muss die Zufallszahl um 1 erhöht werden und die Berechnung nochmal durchgeführt werden. Das heißt, es dauert eine Weile.
Ach so, jetzt verstehe ich. Man muss so lange zufällig etwas erzeugen, bis man ein bestimmtes Pattern hat.
Genau, die ganze Idee dahinter ist, dass man eine Weile rechnen muss. Das dauert auf modernen Rechnern eine Sekunde oder so, um dann diesen Header an die Mail anzuhängen.
Was ist in dem Hasch nochmal drin? Die Uhrzeit, die Absenderadresse, Empfängeradresse?
Ich weiß nicht, ob die Empfängeradresse ist, glaube ich nicht drin. Die wollen halt verhindern, dass Spammer an alle Leute, die...
Aber die könnten doch alle das Gleiche verwenden.
Nein, die Empfängeradresse muss dann auch drin stehen. Die Absenderadresse nicht unbedingt. Die Empfängeradresse muss drin stehen. Und der Zeitstempel.
Der Zeitstempel muss halt nur mit dem über einen... Genau, er muss für den Tag stimmen.
Ich glaube, er gilt für zwei bis drei Tage oder so was. Und dann timet er irgendwie aus. Das heißt, die Spammer müssen halt wirklich alle paar Tage, wenn sie dir einen neuen Spam schicken wollen, einen neuen...
Neuen generieren.
Verstehe.
So, das ist eine Idee, die es so gibt. Also rückwärts zu überprüfen, ist relativ einfach. Man muss ja einfach nur gucken, ob der SHA Key über den... über diesen Header halt 20 Bits Nullen enthält. Das geht ja ratzfatz. Ihn zu erzeugen, dauert halt entsprechend länger.
Das Problem dabei ist doch aber, wie soll man das von jemandem verlangen, den man gar nicht kennt?
Genau, das ist genau das Problem.
Du schickst ja Leute, die ich nicht kenne, wie kann ich von denen erwarten, dass die sowas machen?
Genau.
Vor allem da kommen doch dann die Umweltschützer.
Ja, wahrscheinlich könnten dann so und so viele Atomkraftwerke eingespart werden. Also das ist halt auch... Ich nehme es nicht besonders.
Also es gibt eine Menge innovative Ansätze, aber man kann sich eigentlich auch nicht so richtig einigen. Und interessant finde ich nochmal diesen einen Punkt, was du gerade gesagt hast, Dirk, dass man ja damit sozusagen auch die Anonymität aufgeben würde, weil in dem Moment, wo man jetzt wirklich sagt, okay, alles klar, wir kennen jetzt einfach alle, alle Versender und so weiter sind authentifiziert und registriert und zertifiziert und kryptographisch ist das alles belegbar und beweisbar. Dann lässt sich eben nicht mehr eine E-Mail anonym verschicken, was ja sozusagen das ist, was die Spammer ja eigentlich machen. Bloß gibt es auch da eine legitime Anwendung, die bloß vielleicht nur in einem Myriadsstell der Fälle wirklich zum Einsatz kommt. Jetzt also im Vergleich zu der Anzahl der gesendeten Spam.
Ja, also das Problem ist halt, dass man diese ganzen Dinge kann man halt nicht wirklich verlangen. Das ist halt, wie soll man das machen? Also auch SPF, mal die Probleme, die es halt mal ausgeklammert und mal nur so daherfantasiert, was denn wäre, wenn alle SPF hätten, dann müsstest du halt auch irgendwann anfangen, Mails von von Absender zu sperren, die keinen SPF-Rekord haben. Nur dann könntest du ja wirklich sicher sein, dass das auch mit den... Und das sind leider sehr wenige. Also ich gucke da auch regelmäßig noch rein. Irgendwie, das ist halt letztlich vor allem ein Schutz für dich selber. Also wenn du deiner eigenen E-Mail-Domain eben diesen SPF-Record hinzufügst, dann verhinderst du im Zweifel, dass Spammer deine Absenderadresse verwenden. Weil die sind ja auch nicht doof. Die gucken natürlich auch in DNS und sehen, ah, der SPF, so, das wird wahrscheinlich schwierig. Lass mal mal sein.
Ist ja auch ein soziales Problem, weil ja viele Leute dann auch meinen, man sei jetzt von jemandem gespammt worden, der ist ja eigentlich gar nicht wahr. Und dann gibt es ja auch digitale Racheraktionen noch und nöcher. Das ist ja alles dann nicht mehr schön, wenn die Leute so unzivilisiert aufeinander losgehen. Ich würde ganz gerne nochmal auf die Mailing-Listen einschwenken, aber bevor wir das tun, vielleicht auch nochmal auf die Werkzeuge zurückkommen.
Ja und vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz auch, muss nicht sofort sein, aber was dann nur ist, wenn man die Mail angenommen hat, da hat man ja auch noch diverse Möglichkeiten.
Ach du bist noch bei dem Spam-Ding.
Ja, also wenn die Mail denn mal angekommen ist, bei...
Also wir werden von Spam auch nicht wegkommen, das durchzieht ja jetzt alles. Ich dachte, wir hätten da jetzt dreimal einen Kapitel. Ja, dann bringen wir das mal zu Ende. Und danach wollte ich mal fragen, zu den Werkzeugen, aber go ahead.
Na, ich habe halt noch so einen Spam-Assassin dahinter und Razor 2, glaube ich heißt das so, Razor.
Also wir reden jetzt von, die Mail ist da.
Genau, und man kann genauer drauf schauen.
Wir haben uns geirrt.
Wir wissen es bloß noch nicht. Genau, man weiß noch nicht, ob die jetzt gut oder schlecht ist, sondern man kann sich jetzt mal den Inhalt in Ruhe anschauen. Und dann kann man auch einen Hasch über den Inhalt bilden und dann gibt es Dienste, wo man den Hasch hinschickt und dann sagen die einem zu dem Hasch, ja, das ist Spam, oder nein, das ist, oder wir wissen nicht, ob Spam ist.
Hasch, um es nochmal zu sagen, man hat es eben auch nicht so richtig erklärt. Man nimmt sozusagen die ganze Mail als Datenblock, macht dann eine kropografische Summe darüber und dann kann man halt sicher sein, dass wenn da ein Zeichen anders ist, dann ändert sich halt auch der Hasch. Das heißt, man muss nur noch dieses Endergebnis, diese Zahl vergleichen und kann sich in etwa sicher sein, dass man das gleiche meint.
Jetzt weiß ich auch, wo die ganzen Rechtschreibfehler herkommen, die immer anders sind.
Natürlich. Dieser Ansatz krankt natürlich auch daran, dass die Spammer dann eben minimal ihre Mails verändern. Da ist dann mal ein Space mehr und dann ist der Hasch ein ganz anderer. Deswegen ist das halt auch nicht so richtig effektiv.
War mal gut, ist nicht mehr so effektiv. Das war Razer, genau. Und dann gibt es halt noch Bayes-Filter, also trainierte Korpi, Textkörper halt. Das ist so ein Haufen Text, da hat man einmal gesagt, das war eine gute Mail, das war eine böse Mail. Und dann werden die Worte aus diesen beiden Mails genommen und in entsprechende Töpfe geworfen. Und wenn dann eine unbekannte Mail ankommt, dann wird geguckt, wie viele Worte sind in dem guten Topf, wie viele sind in dem bösen Topf. Und dann wird entschieden, die ist wahrscheinlich nicht so gut. Oder das wird so ein bisschen prozentual immer abgewogen. Und dann baut sich da aber so ein Score auf. Also Spam-Assassin baut dann nach und nach...
Damit kriegt man auf jeden Fall die ganzen Medikamentennamen schon mal ganz ordentlich aussortiert.
Genau, und dann kann eben das... Also Spam-Assassin kann dann eben auch hergehen. Und wenn du das möchtest, dir deinen Subchecked in den Headern halt umschreiben. Du kannst dann so ein Sternchen-Sternchen-Spam davor schreiben, das dann wiederum von deinem Mail-Client entsprechend interpretiert wird und dann schon mal in ein Folder verschoben wird. So dass es also mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit Spam.
Oder dass es dann böse ist, wenn die Mail-Dienst-Strecken... Wenn sie dann nicht Spam war, dann ist sie schon mal so...
Aber sie ist noch da immerhin.
Aber sie ist so modifiziert worden. Dann ist sie in deinem Archiv und hat immer dieses dieses Keinsmal irgendwie, dass sie mal für Spam gehalten worden ist, drauf. Da hab ich auf meinem Mailserver eine interessante Konfiguration. Und zwar, bevor diese Entscheidung gefällt wird, ob etwas wirklich Spam ist oder nicht, also die, wo man so im Zweifel ist, die sozusagen mal so in der Grauzone liegen zwischen könnte Spam sein, könnte nicht Spam sein, wenn die automatisch auf dem Mailserver auf einen bestimmten IMAP-Folder in so ein Spam-Folder einsortiert. Und dann kann man sie halt entweder dort gleich löschen oder man verschiebt sie dann in einen passenden HEM-Folder, der direkt daneben liegt für die Gruppe. Und dann wird sie sozusagen wieder neu eingespielt, als wäre sie jetzt gerade angekommen, aber kriegt sozusagen gleich dieses Approval, ist aber kein Spam.
Und wird auch trainiert gleich.
Genau, und wird dann auch gleich entsprechend trainiert und kommt dann so an, als wäre von vornherein alles prima gewesen und hat eben nicht so ein Brandmal da irgendwie aufgedrückt bekommen. Das ist vor allem super, und an der Stelle setze ich mich so ein, für so E-Mails, die in so komplexen Web-Mail-Interfaces auflaufen. Weißt du, so Request-Tracker und so ein Kram, so Support-Software, wo es dann ein richtiges Elend ist, eine Spam erst mal rauszufischen, wenn die da überhaupt erst mal drin ist, weil die gleich Tickets eröffnet und so weiter, wo man eben mal nicht so Zack-Return machen kann, sondern muss dann irgendwie so komplex auswählen und im Web und dann nochmal und reloaden. Das dauert einfach immer zehn Sekunden, ist einfach ein extremer Vernichter.
Also es gibt auch noch die Möglichkeit, all diese Tools, die so Introspection machen und sich wirklich die Mail anschauen, wiederum als Content-Filter in den MTA, in den Mailserver rein zu hängen und diese ganze Überprüfung zu machen, während die Verbindung zu dem sendenden Computer noch besteht und dann eben mit so einem Scoring arbeitet und sagt, ne, also Entschuldigung, du bist irgendwie bei acht von vier Punkten in meiner Spam-Skala, ich weiß die Mail jetzt ab, tut mir leid, hat dann den Effekt, dass wenn derjenige kein Spammer war, kriegt er einen ordentlichen Bounce und kann eben darauf reagieren. Und wenn er ein Spammer war, dann hat man ja auch ins Schwarze getroffen.
Ordentlicher Bounce heißt, man kriegt so eine kryptische E-Mail, wo drin steht, ich glaube, dass du spammest.
Du wirst auf jeden Fall, auch wenn du die Formulierungen da nicht so schön findest, ist es ja immerhin, du kriegst halt eine Nachricht.
Es ist ja vor allem ein Sprachproblem, man geht ja mal davon aus, dass irgendwie alle Englisch sprechen, aber dem ist ja nicht so.
Naja, also wie willst du es denn wissen?
Na, Fehlermeldungen.
Auf fünf Sprachen oder so.
Nee, das muss ja nur eine Zahl sein, dann kann er das für den Mail-Klient selber übersetzen, wenn er irgendwie 617 und so weiter.
Ach du bist wieder bei Utopien, ja, na klar. Das wäre tatsächlich möglich.
Ich habe noch Hoffnung dann. Wenig, aber ein bisschen ist übrig geblieben. Ich möchte mich eigentlich nur beklagen und wie so ein dicker Gockel auf dem Haar setzen und sagen, ihr seid doch alle doof. Geht hoch weg, nervt mich nicht.
Naja, also das...
Benutzt du auch Spam-Assassin, Daniel? Okay. Ist das immer noch The Tool oder ist euch bloß nichts Besseres eingefallen?
Ich habe keine Lust, mich weiter damit zu beschäftigen. Ich habe so viel Arbeitszeit oder Lebenszeit.
Ja, der Leidensdruck ist im Moment bei mir zumindest auch nicht groß genug, um da jetzt wahnsinnige…
Ich habe auch noch im Client, also im MUA, im Thunderbird, habe ich auch noch mal einen BIOS-Filter. Den trainiere ich eigentlich auch nur noch, den auf dem Server trainiere ich eigentlich schon gar nicht mehr. Das habe ich am Anfang gemacht. Also sozusagen gestaffelte Spam-Filterung. Wobei, was mir aufgefallen ist, ich benutze jetzt auch Google-Mail so ein bisschen, da kommt eigentlich fast gar kein Spam. Und wenn, dann kommt er in Gruppen, wo er sozusagen für die Gruppe autorisiert ist, der Spammer. Also der Spammer ist sozusagen geschafft, die Gruppe was posten zu dürfen. Das ist jetzt kein E-Mail-Spam, sondern eher so Forenspam. Und das ist wirklich einer der Vorteile, die diese großen E-Mail-Provider haben. Die können halt richtig gut Spam filtern. Also, ist meine Meinung.
Ich hab hier gerade keine neuen Nachrichten, aber schon wieder 400. Ich meine, die sind alle schön sortiert in Spam.
Vielleicht guck ich da einfach nicht rein.
Was mich dabei auch...
Ja, doch. Na ja, klar. Also, es gibt dann halt so ein Folder, oder?
Jaja, klar.
Ja, da ist vielleicht was drin, aber da guck ich doch nicht rein.
Aber kriegen die natürlich auch.
Na ja, weil es ist ja geil, wenn es dann kein Nr. ist.
Also, das ist ja das Problem.
Weißt du, du hast es nicht geschafft, am Google-Filter vorbeizukommen, dann bist du es auch nicht wert, von mir gelesen zu werden.
Was mich bei Google so interessieren würde auch ist, wie das sein kann, das ist mir nach wie vor ein Rätsel, dass frisch eröffnete Google-Accounts, und wenn sie noch so einen bekloppten Namen haben, sofort Spam kriegen, sofort. Ich verstehe das nicht.
Das kann ich dir sagen. Diese Spammer, ich sehe ja immer meine Logfals durchscrollen, die probieren einfach alles aus. Die probieren 1, 2, unterstrich, 7, foo, bar, hast du nicht gesehen, aber die probieren einfach alles aus. Und wenn es Vorname, Nachname ist?
Nee, ist es halt nicht. Also du kannst auch irgendwelche Kunstnamen eröffnen, auch mit Ziffern drin, und da hast du eine verdammt schlechte Trefferquote mit Brute Force, und du kriegst daraufhin so ein Fortspray.
Man hat fast das Gefühl, die verkaufen gleich hier drin.
Ja, das ist eben auch meine Überlegung schon gewesen. Also Google muss da direkt irgendwie, weiss ich nicht, wie die mieten das. Die haben Zugang für Spammer.
Aber die sind doch nicht evil.
Die haben so eine API für Spammer. Neuer Account.
Neuer Dienst.
Kaufen sie ihre Spam-Adressen?
Das ist jetzt eine wirklich sehr unausgegorene Verschwörungstheorie, glaube ich.
Nein, nein, das ist keine. Das ist eine Frage. Ich verstehe es einfach nicht.
Ich sehe das wie Dirk, um ehrlich zu sein. Also ich glaube auch, dass die einfach, für die gibt es nicht einen String, den sie nicht erwarten können. Also was Leute sich als E-Mail-Adresse wählen. Also ich glaube, die haben eine Art Spam-Adresse, die sie nicht erwarten können. Also ich glaube, die haben eine Art Spam-Adresse, die sie. Nicht erwarten können. Wenn man so ein Internet verwendet wird, ist den einfach bekannt. Die kaufen sich einfach bei ISPs die notwendigen Daten, die gehen da einfach vorbei. Und ich glaub nicht, dass die Leute sich jetzt bei Gmail besonders viel andere Namen vor dem Ad ausdenken, als sie es bei anderen Domains auch tun würden. Und von daher ist auch glaube ich der Grad an neuen Kombinationen. Ich meine, wenn man sich jetzt so ein E-Mail erkennt, das kannst du doch mal ausprobieren, wenn du dir so ein Password-Generator nimmst.
Ja, das werde ich dann mal tun.
Ja, also was auch immer da ein E-Mail-Kopatin über rauskommt.
Ich stehe da auch eigentlich gar nicht irgendwie auf der Liste der Dinge, die wir hier besprechen wollten.
Naja, so ist das.
Wie auch immer.
Man sollte sowieso bei Podcasts schon gar nicht hier nach irgendwelchen Listen gehen. Zumindest nicht tief religiös. Wir haben alle Zeit der Welt. Wir haben ja schon recht lang einen Podcast erzeugt. Ich sage euch jetzt mal nicht wie lang.
Ich sehe es hier an der WLAN-Uptime.
Lass mal nachher warten.
Ich wollte auch noch irgendwas sagen.
Ich hab ja noch ein paar Themen, also zum Beispiel ganz kurz mal eingeworfen, anonyme E-Mail, es gibt ja so diverse Dienste, kann man auch mal nach googeln bestimmt, zum Beispiel ununbox.net, da kann man sich einfach mal eine temporäre E-Mail-Adresse geben lassen, die trägt man dann irgendwo ein, wo man gerade einen Account für irgendwas haben will, dann kriegt man einmal noch die Antwort, die man braucht, um sozusagen das Passwort zu kriegen im Zweifel, dann hat man seinen Account und auch schön.
Danach geht er nicht mehr.
Da geht er noch einen Schritt weiter.
Dann geht er aber auch nicht mehr.
Genau, die Adresse gibt es dann nicht mehr.
Das heißt, man kann später nicht recoveren darüber, sondern das ist nur so One-Shot.
Genau, One-Shot, es gibt manche, die 24 Stunden halten oder auch mal eine Woche oder auch zur Not auch mal länger, gibt es glaube ich auch als Freie.
Also Dodge It ist so ein Service, da kann man sich einfach, da muss man sich überhaupt nicht anmelden, man sagt einfach, man ist irgendwie blafasel.dodgeit.com Ach und dann guckt man hinterher unter einer URL nach, wo man dieses blafasel dann einsetzt. Und da gibt es kein Passwort für und nichts, aber die lösen.
Die müssen aber viel speichern.
Jaja, ich wundere mich auch, wie die das machen, aber die gibt es schon eine ganze Weile und die verwendet die auch gelegentlich. Das ist wirklich ganz praktisch.
Dodge It. Da muss man sich nicht vorbereiten, das ist praktisch, man kann es einfach nebenbei machen und so.
Du kannst ein RSS-Feed drauf machen und du kannst dann tatsächlich auch für eine kleine Spende deine Mailbox noch mit einem Passwort protekten. Dann kannst du halt die Mail an diese E-Mail-Adresse nur mit einem Passwort lesen. So im Web?
Ja, wenn du die Adresse jemandem rauskriegst, dass der nicht deine Mail bei DoDGE lesen kann. Ach so, die Domain wird wahrscheinlich bald verbrannt sein, oder?
Dachte ich eigentlich, aber ich verwende es, wie gesagt, öfter mal so.
Klingt auch erst mal harmlos.
Gut, das war ein schöner Einwurf. Ja, ich wollte ja noch mal kurz zur Mailing-Liste kommen, aber bevor ich das tue, nochmal zu euren Tools. Da kann man sicherlich noch ein paar Worte zu sagen, weil ihr habt ja jetzt gesagt, was ihr verwendet, aber noch nicht so richtig warum oder was ihr davon haltet. Du, Daniel, hast Postfix am Start. Das ist ja nun wirklich auch einer der populären MTAs.
Ja, also es gibt eine interessante Webseite, die nennt sich mailradar.com. Ich bin mir so ein bisschen unschlüssig darüber, was ich davon halten soll, weil ich nicht weiß, wie es funktioniert. Man kann da sich anschauen, mit welcher Software weltweit so die Mails betrieben werden. Man kann sich da so durchklickern, dann kann zum Beispiel jetzt hier auf Germany gehen und dann sehen, dass in Germany wohl angeblich 35% der Mailserver, also die gehen wirklich nach Servern und nicht nach Traffic oder Domains oder sowas, sondern wirklich die Hosts, angeblich 35% der Server mit großem Abstand übrigens auf Postfix laufen.
9% Open Relays finde ich ganz schön hoch, ehrlich gesagt.
Das steht hier. Das kann man ja noch feststellen, wenn man eine Liste von IP-Adressen oder DNS-Namen hat, kann man ja relativ einfach feststellen, ob irgendein Rechner ein Open Relay ist. Wie man allerdings herausfinden soll, dass es sich um Postfix handelt. Also ich kann ja nur spekulieren, oder vielleicht schreiben sie es auch irgendwo. Ich weiß gar nicht genau geguckt.
Wo hast du denn gerade bitte geguckt?
Ach, in Japan ist Q-Mail ganz vorne.
Na ja, das solltest du einfach mal in Europa ausgewählt verstehen. Deutschland.
Genau, weil eigentlich geht es aus der Kommunikation nicht unbedingt hervor.
Da steht dann nicht in diesen Mailhältern überall drin, welcher Kleint das angefasst hat, mit welcher IP-Adresse. Das kann man ja dann schon auf die Länder...
Das ist die Frage. Dann müssten sie aber wirklich Mails bekommen von irgendwoher.
Oder die Mail mitlesen.
Naja, aber auch das ist nicht so einfach. Also ich hätte eher gedacht, dass sie einfach connecten und dann irgendwie so ein Ding durchspielen und dann anhand von irgendwelchen...
Okay, also die machen jetzt VODO und wir können das glauben oder nicht.
Genau, aber sie schreiben auf jeden Fall das Postfix mit großem Abstand vor.
In Deutschland zumindest.
In Deutschland irgendwie der am meisten verbreitete Mailservice.
Ein Grund mehr, mal da ein paar Worte sozusagen.
In Australien ist Microsoft Mail ganz vorne.
Ja, ist ein schönes Tool auf jeden Fall. Na ja, was gibt es sozusagen? Postfix erfreut sich einer ziemlich lebendigen User-Community, wird aktiv entwickelt. Mir sind sehr wenige, wenn nicht gar keine Security-relevanten Issues bekannt, was dieses Stück Software angeht. Also es gab mal vor ein paar Jahren irgendwie so ein Ding, aber dann haben sie auch sofort nachgelegt. Der einzige Mailserver, muss man fairerweise sagen, der wirklich noch nie irgendwas hatte, was sicherheitsrelevant war, ist Q-Mail. Da hat der Dan Bernstein, der Autor, auch ganz überheblich von Anfang an gesagt, wer hier einen Fehler findet, der kriegt irgendwie, am Anfang waren es glaube ich 500 Dollar, und dann später hat er es irgendwie verdoppelt. Kriegt irgendwie 1000 Dollar sofort auf die Hand. Wer mir hier in der letzten Version meiner Software ein sicherheitsrelevanten Bug nachweist, und hat auch irgendwie keiner geschafft.
Man muss allerdings dazusagen, dass da auch seit 10 Jahren keine Features mehr eingebaut wurden.
Also laut Mailradar sind 100% aller Mail-Server in den Faröer-Inseln Q-Mail.
Aber sie zählen auch nur einen.
Ja, gut, aber dann sag doch mal was zu Postfix. Also wie... also meine... Na ja, ich will jetzt hier nicht durch die Haut töpeln. Vielleicht mal kurz in die Vergangenheit blicken. Sendmail ist glaube ich das Urgestein schlechthin. Also MTAs im Sinne von ich nehme die Mail an und ich leite sie weiter. Also ich spreche SMTP ist Sendmail.
Mhm, glaube ich das.
Aber Sendmail hat auch wirklich nur das gemacht. Es hat nicht POP3 gesprochen, es war jetzt nicht auch noch ein MDA, sondern ein reiner Mail-Annehmer.
Ein reiner MTA mit tatsächlich muss man ja fairerweise sagen auch echt vielen Features.
Ja, absolut.
Mit krankten nur von Anfang an schon immer unter dem Problem, dass die Konfigurationsdatei sendmail.cf, die war halt für Computer gemacht. Wahrscheinlich für viele Systemadministratoren auf dieser Welt so einen Grund über ein Suizid nachzudenken. Also ganz nah an weißem Rauschen, also ausschließlich aus Sonderzeichen bestehend.
Jedes Zeichen hat eine Bedeutung.
Das ist grauenhaft, ganz, ganz grauenhaft. Und man konnte sich das wohl irgendwie erzeugen mit noch vier Makros oder sowas, aber das ist ein...
Kleines A, großes A, großer Unterschied.
Oder ein Punkt am Anfang der Zeile. Ich weiß nicht, ich hab auch 1995 oder so mein erstes Sendmail.cf geschrieben.
Und dein letztes hoffentlich auch.
Ja, danach hab ich dann Q-Mail eingesetzt.
Ja, also das muss man gesehen haben, um zu verstehen, warum wir das auf gar keinen Fall haben.
Und das andere Problem bei Sendmail waren natürlich die regelmäßigen und legendären Sicherheits-Bugs.
Genau, das wurde halt von Anfang an nie irgendwie auf Sicherheit wertgelegt. Es war halt einfach kein Thema in den ersten Tagen.
Und dann war es zu groß, um es nochmal neu zu schreiben. Ich glaube, vielleicht haben Sie es inzwischen sogar neu geschrieben.
Genau, und ich glaube, der erste, der tatsächlich eine ernsthafte Alternative dazu vorgelegt hat, war dann Dan Bernstein mit Q-Mail, oder?
Es gab schon ein S-Mail, gab es auch schon vorher.
Ah, das, was heute X7 heißt.
Ah, nee, ich habe es bestimmt. Ich habe zuerst S-Mail nach Sendmail eingesetzt. Das war schon eine deutliche Verbesserung in der Konfiguration.
Also S-Mail ist auch noch ganz alte Zeit. Das war Anfang der 90er Jahre, gab es das schon.
Und der Grund für S-Mail war bestimmt auch, dass Sendmail so ein schoßliches Konfigurationsformat hatte.
Genau. Ja, da kann ich mich auch noch dran erinnern. Ich hatte auch mal eine Weile lang S-Mail.
Man muss echt sagen, die hatten halt wirklich so Features, dass man wirklich, basierend auf Kombinationen wie woher kommt die Mail, wohin geht die Mail, bestimmte Aktionen einleiten kann. Das ist tatsächlich nicht so trivial zu machen.
Richtiger Mail-Router.
Ja, ja. Also wirklich konfigurieren wir bis ins letzte Detail. Deswegen halt auch so unglaublich kompliziert. Und wie gesagt, das Schlimmste daran waren natürlich die ganzen Security-relevanten Fnots, die sie sich so geleistet haben über die Jahre.
Aber warum hast du jetzt Postfix genommen? Weil es die Nummer 1 war in Deutschland.
Naja, ich habe zusammengearbeitet mit einem Kollegen, der sich auf Postfix spezialisiert hatte und hat mir das so nebenbei bringen lassen. Und überzeugt bin ich glaube ich nach wie vor davon, weil es wirklich ein sehr stabil laufendes System ist. Und wie gesagt, Security-relevante Geschichten gab es jetzt eigentlich auch nicht in letzter Zeit.
Also Postfix und Q-Mail waren die beiden ersten Mailer, also Q-Mail zuerst und dann Postfix, die wirklich Sicherheit großgeschrieben haben, also für die Sicherheit ein Kernbestandteil war. Ich weiß nicht, ob es bei Postfix geht es da auch so weit, dass jede Funktion einen eigenen Account verwendet und nur bestimmte Teile des Systems, also verschiedene Prozesse auf bestimmte Verzeichnisstrukturen zugreifen dürfen, geht das so? Die Trennung gibt es da auch.
Ja, also du hast eigene Demons für jeden Subprozess, den so eine Mail durchläuft. Also Mail annehmen und dann entsprechend weiterleiten und dann auf die Platte schreiben. Das sind alles eigene Dienste, die dann eben entsprechend auch ihre Rechte beraubt werden können.
Und es läuft als Root.
Na, dummerweise ein Teil muss als Root laufen.
Der in Port 25 bindet, aber doch nur so lange, bis er ihn gebunden hat.
Danach kann er seine Privileges auch droppen. Da wird aber bei Postfix auch ganz, ganz viel Wert drauf gelegt. Man kann eben auch, wenn man das richtig konfiguriert, die Dienste, die nicht unbedingt auf die Platte Zugriff haben, müssen zum Beispiel auch sehr rooten und so. Aber es geht wahrscheinlich jetzt wirklich zu weit. Es wird jedenfalls ziemlich viel Wert gelegt auf Sicherheit auch.
Und auch auf Betriebsstabilität, denn dass das Mail der Format unterstützt wird, bedeutet ja auch, dass die Mail auch wirklich auf der Platte ist und nicht eine Mail die ganze M-Box zerschießen kann. So wie bei Sendmail kann das ja durchaus passieren, dass wenn eine Mail gelöscht wird im M-Box-Format, dann muss ja das gesamte M-Box-Fail wieder rausgeschrieben werden.
Ja, also der Unterschied ist, M-Box basiert auf einer einzigen großen Datei, in der alle Mails auf der Reihe nach gespeichert werden. Und wenn ich das richtig weiß, wurden zwei Mails getrennt, in dem man einfach... Wenn dann eine Mail dazwischen war, die da eben nicht richtig irgendwie beendet wurde, dann waren alle weiteren Mails irgendwie, oder sind alle weiteren, es gibt ja noch Verwendete, soweit ich weiß, sind alle weiteren Mails nicht mehr lesbar. Das ist halt eine ziemliche Krankheit. Und Mail.Dear verwendet eben eine Datei pro E-Mail.
Was sehr sehr sinnvoll ist.
Und Mail.Dear funktioniert sogar sicher über NFS, weil es noch so einen Temp.Dear und einen Current.Dear und einen New.Dear hat. Und die werden dazwischen gemuft. Und erst, wenn sie sozusagen am Schluss angekommen sind, sagt der Mail, also der SMTP-Server, okay, ich hab die Mail angenommen. Und dann ist sie aber auch wirklich auf der Platte.
Nee, wenn man Zweifel auf jeden Fall hat. Übrigens, Cyrus verwendet an der Stelle ja auch, ich glaube er nach wie vor ausschließlich, bin ich da richtig informiert, sein eigenes proprietary Format.
DovCut war übrigens einer der Gründe, weshalb ich das eingesetzt habe, weil das Mail-Dier-Supporter hat.
Ja, und gut, dann ist eigentlich zu den beiden Programmen alles gesagt. Also Postfix und Q-Mail bestechen beide durch Sicherheit und durch eine Konfiguration, die jetzt nicht so komplett anal fixiert ist, wie bei Sendmail.
X-Team sollte man auf jeden Fall noch erwähnen. Ich hab jetzt persönlich wenig Erfahrung damit, aber ich kenne ganz viele Leute, die total draufschwören und die werden sicherlich ihre Gründe haben. Mir ist jetzt auch nicht bekannt, warum man X-Team irgendwie...
Ich glaube, man hat so die Flexibilität von Sendmail mit einem... Also X-Team ist ja auch der Nachfolger von S-Mail. Und ist halt sehr flexibel. Also ich kenn's auch nicht so gut. Ich würde auch eher auf Postfix wechseln, wenn ich wechseln würde von Q-Mail.
Ja, also es gibt halt irgendwie diverse... Auf Wikipedia findet man auch eine riesige Liste von anderen. Die Leute von kernel.org, also wo die Linux Kernels gehostet werden, und auch diverse Mailing-Listen, die ja auch hohen Traffic haben, um es vorsichtig auszudrücken. Die verwenden zum Beispiel ein Tool namens Z-Mailer, das ich jetzt persönlich auch noch nie eingesetzt habe. Aber die haben ja schon irgendwie bewiesen, dass es funktioniert.
Dann kommen wir da mal kurz noch zu dem Punkt Mailing-Listen. Das ist ja an sich eine praktische Geschichte. Mailing-Listen taugen nicht für alles, aber für manche Sachen ganz hervorragend. Du bist ja einer von zweien Mailing-Listen-Server betrieben für den Club. Der hat ja eine ganze Menge davon. Was kommt denn da zum Einsatz?
Na, das ist auch Q-Mail und EZMLM. Und EZMLM ist auch so ein bisschen der Grund, warum wir da bei Q-Mail bleiben müssen, weil EZMLM halt diese Verbs, diese Variable Envelope Response Paths verwendet. Was den Vorteil hat, dass die Bounce-Verwaltung, wenn User nicht mehr auf der Liste sind oder wenn ihr Account nicht mehr funktioniert, dass dann die Bounce es halt automatisch von der Listen-Software verwaltet.
Das hast du ja vorhin schon mal erläutert. Und das ist natürlich für so High-Volume-Listen. Aber EasyMLM ist gemacht für Q-Mail. Also er kann nicht ohne Q-Mail leben.
Ich hatte mal gerüchteweise gehört, dass es auch mit Postfix geht, aber das ist wohl nicht so. Also kann man da nicht wechseln, leider.
Kennt ihr denn eigentlich einen Mailing-Listen-Hoster, wo man einfach...
Seine Mailing-Liste hosten kann? Ja, bei Yahoo-Groups ist so was.
Ja, aber die zwingen einen dann doch, so Yahoo-Accounts zu eröffnen, genauso wie Gmail.
Nein, bei Google-Groups kann man auch subscriben ohne Google-Account. Bin ich mir ziemlich sicher. Google-Groups wäre dann das andere. Kann man wie eine Mailing-Liste betreiben. Man hat natürlich immer noch dieses Web-Interface, aber es ist öffentlich sozusagen.
Ja, aber man muss sich doch da in das Google-Mail-System...
Ja, aber du kannst ja inzwischen beliebige Adressen angeben.
Man muss seine Adresse sozusagen einmal als Google-Account eintragen.
Ich dachte, man könnte da beliebige E-Mail... Also man könnte wie eine Mailing-Liste vom Interface her, ich schicke eine Mail hin, subscribe mich, kriege eine Mail zurück, bin subscribt, fertig. So habe ich das verstanden.
Vielleicht geht es nicht. Okay, wir reden wieder über Sachen, die wir nicht wirklich wissen. Ich werde dafür Tipps auf jeden Fall zu haben. Machst du Mailing-Listen, Daniel?
Nicht mehr. Ich habe das früher mal verwaltet und ich bin gerade am überlegen, was wir damals verwendet haben.
Wahrscheinlich Major Domo, oder?
Ja, Major Domo haben wir auch eingesetzt.
Den haben wir mal verwendet.
Das ist ja so der Grand Senior der Mailing-Listen.
Und Mailman, genau. Wobei ich mich da jetzt auch irgendwie nicht zu einer Aussage hinreißen lassen möchte, was ich davon empfehlen würde, weil das ist zu lange her, die haben sich wahrscheinlich weiterentwickelt und muss man nochmal neu forschen, was davon taugt und was nicht.
EZMLM kann halt, ach noch ein wichtiges Feature, das können aber inzwischen alle glaube ich, ist, dass nur Subscriber posten dürfen. So wird man halt den gesamten Spam los. Man hat dann keinen Spam, weil nur Leute, was auf die Liste schreiben dürfen, die auch subscribt sind.
Klar, das muss sein.
Führt manchmal noch zu extra Problemen, dass die von anderen Adressen posten wollen und dann erst mal ihre Adresse eintragen lassen müssen. Aber das können sie auch per Mail machen, da muss nicht der Administrator was zu tun.
Was mich so ein bisschen wundert ist, ich habe bisher noch keinen Mailclient, keinen Moa getroffen, der jetzt so auf der Benutzerseite so out of the box Mailing-Listen-Support hätte. Weil eine wohl konfigurierte Mailing-Liste, so wie ich es jetzt vor allem von den CCC-Mailing-Listen gewohnt bin, haben ja eine ganze Batterie von wohl spezifizierten Headern. Das heißt, wenn so eine Mail von einer Mailing-Liste kommt, dann weiß man erst mal, es handelt sich hier um eine Mail von einer Mailing-Liste und welche Mailing-Liste. Da ist dann eine deutliche ID drin. Das kann man ja auch schön automatisch filtern. Also wenn man so mit Sortier-Move, Folder-Move-Regeln vertraut ist, dann kann man damit schon ganz gut arbeiten. Ich frage mich immer nur, warum bieten Programme keinen speziellen Mailing-Listen-Support an?
Ich glaube, diese Header sind nicht Mailing-Listen-Manager übergreifend standardisiert. ZMLM hat halt seine Header und Mailman hat seine Header. Oder sind es die gleichen Header?
Soweit ich weiß, ist das...
List-ID könnte glaube ich bei allen gleich. Aber das ist dann Zufall. Da hat sich glaube ich niemand hingesetzt und gesagt, wir machen das jetzt so.
Doch, da gibt es einen RFC für. RFC2919 redet so von List-ID und von all diesen anderen. Da gibt es Headers, um zu sagen, welche Mailing-Liste das ist, wie man sich da subscribt, wie man sich da unsubscribt und so weiter. Was für mich ein echt großes Problem ist...
Anfang 2001, ich habe 1999 aufgehört.
Was ich z.B. sträflich vermisse, ist, ich möchte gerne, dass mein Programm, also erst mal, wenn so eine Mail kommt, sagt irgendwie, oh, hallo, es sieht so aus, als ob du auf einer Mailing-Liste bist, und das dann einfach entsprechend gleich schon mal so automatisch wegsortiert und dass ich mir das einfach so... Ein Folder, der einfach auftaucht. Genau, ein Smart-Folder, der einfach sagt, hier Mailing-Liste, tralala, und dass ich dann auch dafür bestimmte Settings machen kann, wie z.B., was immer ein großes Problem ist... Nimm diese Adresse. Genau, welche Absende-E-Mail-Adresse verwendest du für diese Mailing-Liste, dass man da eben auch mit einer anderen Identität drauf posten kann und nicht permanent dieses Problem hat, dass man dann eine Mail hinschickt und dann kriegt man wieder zurück mit, du darfst hier gar nicht posten, weil...
Du bist ja Tim et Tu und nicht Tim et Bla.
Genau. Das prangere ich auch an. Ja, du sitzt jetzt hier noch und prangere an, weil mich das aber schon total zu scheiße genervt hat.
Also MUT hat sowas.
Vielleicht hört ja jemand zu.
Das ist natürlich jetzt kein Programm, das man irgendwie jedem zumuten möchte, aber MUT ist in der Lage.
Ja, ich rede so von GUI-Software, die Kommando-Zeilen, Mailing-Lines, sind natürlich extrem versatil.
Für Thunderbird gibt es bestimmt ein Plug-In für sowas. Aber du nimmst Thunderbird nicht.
Nee, ich nimm Thunderbird nicht.
Kein religiösen Krieg.
Nein, nein, ich will gar nicht mit anfangen. Ich habe einfach konkrete Gründe, warum ich Thunderbird nicht benutzen kann. Auch da musste ich jetzt mal wieder hinschauen, aber last time I checked, war das Ding irgendwie nicht in der Lage, Mails nach Eingangsdatum zu sortieren und außerdem nur nach dem Datum, was da drinsteht. Und wenn er halt 1. Januar 1970 in der Mail steht, weil wieder einer seine Uhr nicht mehr bekommen hat.
Und du kannst nach Nummer sortieren und nach Order received. Das geht schon. Dann hast du das Problem nicht. Ob nun Order oder richtiger Zeitpunkt, ist ja für die Sortierung auch irrelevant. Also Order geht.
Ja, aber dann nervt mich einfach immer, dass die Dreiecke falsch rum sind. Ich weiß ja nicht, was sie da geritten hat, aber sie machen die Dreiecke halt so wie auf Linux und nicht wie auf Mac.
Ein anderer Wort ist, wenn du Threading einschaltest, also sagst du, du hättest gerne deine Mails gethreaded. Und dann hast du den Thread, der war vor 5 Monaten mal aktiv, und dann schreibt noch mal einer, was an diesen Thread von vor 5 Monaten, aber noch was Aktuelles, dann siehst du das einfach nicht, weil es nicht wie bei Mail-App nach unten gezogen wird oder nach oben, je nachdem, wie die Reihenfolge ist. Sondern es bleibt dann da, wo die ursprünglichen, also das bleibt immer vor 5 Monaten stehen, was total gaga ist.
Man könnte sagen, da gehört es auch hin.
Nee, überhaupt nicht. Weil bis ich es da finde, da muss ich ja scrollen.
Also wahrscheinlich ist der Kommentarbereich jetzt in diesem Blog groß.
Und ich habe sogar schon ein Plug-in gefunden, was genau dieses Problem lösen soll. Leider hat es bei mir nicht funktioniert. Es ist ein bekanntes Problem.
Ich wollte das fast auch nicht wirklich aufmachen. Ich wollte einfach nur sagen, generell fände ich es schön, wenn es ordentlich Mailing-Listen-Support gäbe, weil Mailing-Listen eine dieser untapped Ressourcen sind im Internet, die einfach zu wenig Leute benutzen. Insbesondere, ich merke das halt, wenn man hier so Leute, ich weiß nicht, so normale Menschen, die einfach das Internet wirklich gelegentlich benutzen, die man aber dann trotzdem in so eine Mailing-Liste mit einbinden möchte, ohne sie zu zwingen, irgendeinen Sign-Up durchzuführen, sondern die einfach nur auf diese Mailing-Liste gesetzt werden sollen. Und dann funktioniert das automatisch. Und sie benutzen es auch automatisch, richtig, weil ihr Client ihnen dabei hilft. Das ist einfach ein Problem.
Wo wir gerade bei Threads waren, an der Stelle könnte man vielleicht auch nochmal ganz kurz erklären, wie denn ein Threading überhaupt, also wie ein, nur eine Frage, das...
Vielleicht erstmal sagen, was wir meinen mit Threads.
Also ein Thread entsteht immer dann, wenn mehrere Leute auf eine E-Mail antworten.
Also ein Diskussionsstrang.
Und das ist jetzt eine ausschließende Frage des User-Clients, wie er den Support dafür gestaltet. Fakt ist jedenfalls, dass alle mir bekannten User-Clients bei einem Reply auf eine E-Mail, die übrigens also jede E-Mail, die erzeugt wird, hat eine vom User-Client erzeugte eindeutige ID, die man auch sieht, wenn man sich die Header anschaut. Und diese ID wird eingefügt als Reference, also der neu erzeugte Reply auf eine E-Mail hat immer ein Vermerk, dass diese E-Mail sich auf eine vorherige bezieht. Und wenn die dann ankommt, also geht dann im Zweifel einmal über den Mail-Listenserver und kommt zurück, dann sieht der Client, aha, diese Antwort referenziert auf eine E-Mail, die habe ich ja auch schon hier in meiner Liste irgendwo, die ID kenne ich doch. Also male ich sie direkt darunter und kann dann sagen, das ist eine Antwort auf die E-Mail, die ich hier schon im Postfach habe. Das hat einen unschönen Nebeneffekt.
Es hat aber auch gute Seiten.
Nein, es hat sehr viele gute Seiten. Also das ist absolut richtig, wie es ist. Das Problem ist, nur wenn Leute tendieren noch dazu, vor allem, wenn sie sich nicht so richtig auskennen mit dem Medium E-Mail, auf eine Mail-Liste zu posten, indem sie einfach einen Reply formulieren und dann das Subject austauschen.
Statt den Namen der Liste einzutragen.
Genau, und den gesamten Inhalt der Mail auch löschen und dann eine neue Mail anfangen, was im Prinzip auch funktioniert, nur den unschönen Nebeneffekt hat, dass diese Antwort auf diese Mail-Liste dann als Antwort auf eine andere E-Mail landet, die man gar nicht sieht, weil der Thread nie interessiert hat. Genau, und das ist nicht gut. Das sollte man an der Stelle erwähnen, das macht man nicht. Man drückt auf neue E-Mail direkt ganz brav den Mailing-Listen-Namen ein.
Mein Mail-Client hat tatsächlich ein Feature, dass wenn ich da auf die Mail, auf den Upsender draufklicke, dass ich dann sagen kann, New Message an diesen...
Aber wer es nicht weiß...
Aber das findet bestimmt auch kein Mensch.
Ja, aber wer es nicht weiß, der ist halt schon tempted, da einfach mit...
Schlimmer finde ich aber, dass man Mail Klein nicht wirklich mehr so einen hierarchischen Thread macht, sondern eigentlich nur so ein Level. Das ist auch ganz unanständig.
Damit ist auch jedem klar, von welchem Mail Klein du sprichst.
Aber, immerhin ist es nicht mehr so... Der Vorteil dieser Reference-Header ist auch, dass man das Subject mal ändern kann während eines Threads. In der Regel sagt man dann ein neues Subject, in Klammern War oder Was, Doppelpunkt, altes Subject.
Kommt doch mal klar, Klammer auf, Was, Flame, War, Klammer zu.
Wo wir schon dabei sind, bei Don'ts, der E-Mail-Kommunikation, sollten wir vielleicht an der Stelle... Na ja gut, das ist vielleicht eher stilistisch. Was aber ein echtes Problem darstellt, ist das Nichtverwenden von BCC. Das sollte man auf jeden Fall an der Stelle vielleicht auch noch mal erwähnen. Dass es leider immer noch sehr viele Menschen gibt, die Mail an 80, 100, keine Ahnung...
Leute, die sich nicht kennen.
Leute, die sich nicht kennen, verschicken eine Einladung für irgendwas, oder Neujahrsgrüße oder sonst irgendeinen Blödsinn. Und sich gar nicht darüber im Klaren sind, was sie damit anrichten. Das hat da nichts verloren.
Also was sie machen ist, dass sie 50 Leute ins Tofu packen. Und alle sehen alle. Das ist nicht nur eine Datenschutzdiskussion, sondern das führt dazu, dass wenn die dann antworten, auch alle antworten.
Weil die dann gerne auch mal Reply All sagen. Das wäre auch schönes Neues.
Aber die Frage ist, an wen schickt man denn dann die Mail? Weil es ja häufig die Software nicht kann, dass man sagt, schick mal diese Mail 50 mal an jeden, der in dieser Liste ist.
Im Grunde kann man sich da eine Fantasieadresse ausdenken und alle Empfänger ins BCC schreiben.
Ja, aber dann rumpelt diese Fantasieadresse meistens halt durch irgendein Spam-Filter wieder durch oder wird halt nicht ordentlich einsortiert.
Und schreibst alle Leute ins BCC.
Ja, aber dann empfange ich eine Mail, die an mich geht.
Ja, und?
Nein, wenn ich jetzt der Adressat bin, meine ich. Dann erhalte ich eine Mail, wo drin steht, dass die an den ist, der sie geschickt hat. Und das landet in meinem Mail-Programm auf jeden Fall schon mal in einem Krankenort.
Na gut. Ja, da gibt es schon Spam-Filter, die darauf reagieren.
Ja, ist aber im Zweifel tatsächlich das kleinere Problem.
Aber du schlägst vor, dass man halt bitte BCC benutzt, also Blind-Carbon-Copy, nicht CC, nicht TUR.
Genau, was den Unterschied hat für diejenigen, die es vielleicht nicht kennen, dass die Adressaten die Leute, die im BCC fährt, an einer Mail standen, nicht sehen. Wann immer es keinen Grund gibt, an alle zu antworten, die eine Mail bekommen haben, sollte man das so machen. Denn das große Problem ist, dass daher leider auch mal eine ganze Menge Spam kommt. Also wenn jetzt 80 Leute adressiert werden in dieser E-Mail, und ich stehe da unter anderem drin, dann habe ich 80 potentiell amok laufende Windows-Kisten mit irgendwelchen Viren und Würmern da draußen stehen, die mir dann theoretisch, wenn der Wurm da das Adressbuch durchguckt, natürlich irgendwie Spam zuschicken. Also ich kriege von 80 Adressen potentiell Spam. Und 80 andere auch. Also 80 zum Quadrat potentielle Spam-E-Mails, die dadurch erzeugt werden. Und das ist ein riesen Problem. Deswegen darf man das nicht machen.
Ja, wollen wir jetzt hier das religiöse...
Nein, nein, das hat mit religiös nichts zu tun.
Nein, nein, das hat nichts mit religiös zu tun. Ich wollte nur fragen, ob wir jetzt sozusagen noch den nächsten Schritt gehen sollen und auch die ganzen anderen religiösen Pulsabfässer öffnen sollen. Was zur E-Mail... Ja, das würde mir da zum Beispiel auch einfallen.
Also da bin ich...
Reply to auf Mailing-Listen.
Das ist wirklich eine widerliche Diskussion.
Das sollten wir vielleicht nicht führen.
Nee, das stimmt nicht.
Und Tofu hast du gerade erwähnt.
Da geht es dann mehr so darum, wie man Antworten...
Ich habe mich jetzt daran gewöhnt, ein Tofu. Ich könne damit leben. Text oben, Vollquot unten.
Das ist so eine typisch deutsche Geschichte. Das merkt man schon an der Abkürzung, oder? Um sowas kümmert sich wirklich nur Deutsche. Ich glaube, das ist dem Rest des Internets sowas.
Von Scheiß egal. Meines Erachtens, ich wehre mich dagegen, das in gleichem Atemzug mit nicht verwendetem BCC zu erwähnen, weil das eine wirklich ein richtiges Problem darstellt und das Kommunikationsmittel im Internet in seinen Prinzipien gefährdet.
Ich wollte jetzt auch nicht damit anfangen, Tofu einfach nur eine stilistische Geschichte zu machen. Vierzeilige Signatures einzuklagen. Lassen wir das. Das führt zu gar nichts. Jetzt sind wir auch hier einmal schon durch alle Nerd-Untiefen durchgegangen mit Kryptographen und Hashes. Ich denke nicht, dass wir jetzt schon am Ende dieses Podcasts noch mit einer anderen Gruppe zu tun haben, die wir diese Diskussion auch zwingen müssen.
Das haben wir noch, stimmt.
Das halten wir auf jeden Fall noch an. Vorratsdatenspeicherung und E-Mail-Überwachung.
Das machen wir jetzt mal zum Abschluss. Wir lassen jetzt die Technik mal sein. Wir haben 100.000 Sachen nicht erwähnt. Wir wissen das. Dieses Thema ist sowieso unendlich. Aber ihr habt ja gehört, was wir auf dem Herzen hatten. Jetzt haben wir aber auch noch ein anderes Problem. Das ist der Überwachungsstaat greift zu und möchte gerne alles mitschreiben. Ihr habt euch mal ein bisschen schlau gemacht. Wie sieht das aus? Vorratsdatenspeicherung und E-Mail? Welche Auswirkungen hat das?
Wir fangen mal mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung an. Die wirkt jetzt mal, erzähle ich mal, wo sie nicht wirkt, weil das sie eigentlich schon ad absurdum führt. Sie wirkt nicht bei meinem privaten Mailserver und bei deinem oder unserem privaten Mailserver. Da findet überhaupt keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung statt. Jedenfalls nicht nach dem, wie es jetzt gerade so geplant ist. Sondern die E-Mail-Adressen, Sender, Empfänger, Uhrzeit, das war es, IP-Adressen vielleicht noch, die beteiligt sind, oder Mailserver, das wird nur gespeichert bei den großen E-Mail-Provider, also bei, weiß ich nicht, t-online, web.de, GMX und wie sie alle heißen. Google Mail zum Beispiel wahrscheinlich auch nicht, weil die ja in Amerika sitzen und ich glaube nicht, dass da die Vorratsdatenspeicherung so direkt...
Ja, sie gilt.
Für wen gilt sie?
Sie gilt für Anbieter, die dritten diesen Service der E-Mail zugänglich machen. Davon betroffen sind meines Wissens auch nicht Firmen, die 20.000 E-Mail-Accounts im Keller verwalten. Sie sind dafür nicht betroffen, weil sie diesen Dienst nicht öffentlich anbieten, sondern nur für sich selber gebrauchen. Die sind, glaube ich, auch nicht davon betroffen.
Nee, ich glaube auch nicht. Deshalb ist diese Vorratsdatensprechung nur dafür da, die Dummen, die zu GMX gehen, zu kriegen. Wenn ich Verbrecher wäre, würde ich einfach mal nicht zu solchen Anbietern gehen. Damit ist das schon total für die Katz.
Du gehst da ja auch nicht hin.
Genau.
Heißt das, du bist ein Verbrecher? Das macht man sich ja schon mal verdächtig. Aha, eigener Mail-Server.
Ich weiß es nicht. Und dann gibt es noch E-Mail-Überwachung. Das ist auch bei diesen Providern ab 10.000 Adressen-Anbietern, also Anbieter, die mehr als 10.000 Adressen anbieten. Die müssen sich eine Box installieren lassen, womit dann auch der verschlüsselte Traffic entschlüsselt wird, falls die E-Mails per Web-Interface abgerufen werden können oder per HTTPS. Da wird sozusagen eine Box beim Provider installiert, dass dieser HTTPS-Traffic entschlüsselt wird, entweder weil er dort terminiert in der Box und dann sozusagen entschlüsselt zu dem eigentlichen Web-Server geht und dabei abgegriffen wird oder keine Ahnung, wie die Box das sonst macht. Vielleicht entschlüsselt sie auch, weil sie die Keys kennt, einfach so die Verbindung, die da vorbeikommt.
Auf welcher Basis ist diese...
Das ist die Sina-Box, die bei großen Providern inzwischen... Die steht da schon eine Weile.
Ich meine, auf welcher rechtlichen Basis steht das?
Das steht in der Wikipedia unter E-Mail-Überwachung.
Könnte man jetzt einfach aus der Wikipedia vorlesen.
Die Frage, warum, weiß ich nicht. Aber es gibt eine gesetzliche Grundlage dafür, und die gibt es auch schon recht lange. Die ist sogar älter als die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, das E-Mail.
Ach so, das ist die Telekommunikations-Überwachungsverordnung.
Genau, das heißt, da muss es einen Bedarfsträger geben, also einen Richter in dem Fall, oder auch diverse Bundesbehörden oder Landesbehörden, Verfassungsschutz, Toll, Polizei etc. Wenn die sagen, wir wollen mal einen bestimmten E-Mail-Account jetzt mal abhören, dann gehen sie halt zu dem Provider, nein, dann gehen sie nicht zu dem Provider, dann gehen sie in ihr VPN und loggen sich beim Provider ein und schnorcheln dann da alles mit. Und es geht sogar so weit, dass der Provider eigentlich gar nichts davon wissen darf, dass die jetzt konkret eine Maßnahme gegen irgendwen gerade führen. Angeblich, nein, nicht angeblich, also sie sollen denjenigen, der davon betroffen ist, hinterher informieren, aber bei der Telefonüberwachung wissen wir ja, dass das nicht passiert faktisch. Also wird es bei der E-Mail-Überwachung vermutlich auch nicht passieren. Was, also schließen wir daraus, macht euren eigenen Mailserver. Das kann man nur raten.
Oder baut irgendwelche privaten Communities auf mit fähigen Administratoren.
Ja, oder genau, Privat-VPNs oder...
Was übrigens angeblich ja auch nicht davon betroffen ist, ist der Inhalt der E-Mail?
Nicht bei der VDS, aber schon bei der Telekommunikationsüberwachung, oder?
Also in dem Moment, wo sie dir jetzt speziell ans Leder wollen. Schauen sie sich schon deine Mail an. Die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist noch nicht so weit, dass sie so viel Kapazität haben, dass sie nicht schon mitlesen können.
Ja, und vor allem kann man das eben auch... Das sollten wir vielleicht... Ich meine, wir haben jetzt noch überhaupt nicht über E-Mail-Verschlüsselung...
Das dürfen wir jetzt sozusagen als Schlussthema jetzt noch aufgreifen.
Genau, also E-Mail-Verschlüsselung in der Mail selber hat man jetzt noch gar nicht. Da gibt es im Wesentlichen auch nur zwei konkurrierende Verfahren, die mir zumindest bekannt sind. Die beide leider nicht zum Einsatz kommen. Das eine ist PGP bzw. die freie Implementierung von GPG und das andere sind die X-509-Zertifikate.
Tja, beides hat so seine Vor- und seine Nachteile. Ich... Tja. Also das Hauptproblem bei dieser ganzen Verschlüsselung sind halt diese Zertifikate, also bei der S-Mime-basierten. Also viele Clients unterstützen halt S-Mime, wenige unterstützen GPG out of the box, was auch nicht so ohne Weiteres zu machen ist, weil wenn man jetzt GPG verwendet, ist ja irgendwie Gnu-Software und das kann man nicht einfach so einbauen. Das heißt, häufig hat man Plug-In und ruft dann halt die separat installierte Software auf, die einem dann eben die Mail entsprechend schiffriert oder deschiffriert. Bei PGP hat man es halt mit dem Web of Trust zu tun. Das heißt, man kann sich seinen eigenen Schlüssel definieren, erzeugen und mit anderen Leuten dann eben den öffentlichen Teil tauschen und dann kann man sich halt gegenseitig verschüsselte Mails schicken. Man ist dann von keiner zentralen Instanz abhängig. Web of Trust ist ja nur insofern interessant, als dass man sich eben gegenseitig dann noch da auf den Arsch kitzeln kann und sich gegenseitig seine Schlüssel unterschreiben kann, um eben dritten Gegenüber da eine Sicherheitssimulation zu bieten, dass das wohl schon der richtige Schlüssel ist, wenn man den jetzt nicht direkt bekommen hat.
Aber ist wahrscheinlich tatsächlich auch ein Thema, da könnte man einen weiteren Podcast...
Da kann man ewig drum reden, aber ich würde jetzt da, dass eigentlich, sagen wir mal, der GPG-Teil auch schon 1000 Mal besprochen wurde, schon noch mal hinterfragen, was eure Erfahrungen mit SMIME sind. Weil das findet sich natürlich jetzt in vielen kommerziellen Clients auch einfach so mit drin. Der Vorteil ist der... Naja, also...
Ich hab da überhaupt keine Erfahrungen.
Ich hab das zumindest mal so ein bisschen irgendwie gemacht. Ich meine, wenn du jetzt...
Mit wem denn?
Ich kenne auch ganz wenig Leute, die das wirklich machen.
Naja, jeder der SMIME verwendet und seine Mails signiert, da ist ja dann der Key sozusagen, den ich brauche drin. Ich muss nämlich nicht separat nochmal diesen Key besorgen, sondern in dem Moment, wo ich das erste Mal für ihn eine Mail bekomme, sehe ich, ah, der benutzt Verschlüsselung und kann mit den in dieser Mail enthaltenen Informationen sofort verschlüsselt antworten. Vorausgesetzt, dass ich selber so ein Zertifikat habe.
Und vorausgesetzt, dass derjenige sein Zertifikat unterschrieben lassen hat von einem, von einer RUCA, der mein E-Mail-Klein auch vertraut.
Und damit steht und fällt das ganze Ding.
Ja, weil dann muss man irgendwann einmal diesem RUCA halt glauben. Und nur, wenn man das getan hat.
Ja, aber der große Vorteil ist, ich muss mir nicht wirklich jeden einzelnen Key separat organisieren, mir irgendwelche Fingerprints durchlesen und so. Sondern ich verlasse mich halt auf ein existierendes Zertifikatsystem, wie sehr man dem jetzt sozusagen traut oder nicht traut. Das steht nochmal auf einer ganz anderen Seite. Ich habe mal eine Weile mit den CAZ-Sachen gearbeitet. Also wenn du bei CAZ-Org, da wo man sich eben die kostenlosen SSL-Zertifikate holen kann, da kann man sich halt auch E-Mail-Zertifikate erzeugen lassen, wenn man da einen Account hat. Da kann man also seine E-Mail-Adresse eintragen, sich dafür was machen lassen. Das heißt, mit anderen, die eben auch CAZ als Zertifikatsinstanz akzeptieren, das ist natürlich auch quasi niemand.
Die machen jetzt auch Dicht, habe ich gehört.
Geht das schon. Die Zukunft des Projekts ist nochmal eine andere Geschichte. Also beides ist irgendwie blöd und de facto nutzt eigentlich niemand wirklich Verschlüsselung, es sei denn...
Er hat was zu verbergen.
Er hat wirklich was zu verbergen, was natürlich ein doppeltes Elend ist. Und ich sehe auch ehrlich gesagt derzeit da so recht keinen Ausweg. Es gibt irgendwie nichts, was zwischen diesen beiden Systemen ist.
Man müsste sich wahrscheinlich wirklich mit dem ganzen Thema S-Mime und GNU-BG wahrscheinlich nochmal mit einer ganz eigenen Sendung beschäftigen. Aber vielleicht noch ein kurzes Detail dazu. Was verschlüsselt wird mit diesen Systemen, ist der Buddy der E-Mail. Und was nicht zum Buddy der E-Mail gehört, wird auch nicht verschlüsselt. Das Subject ist nämlich Teil des Headers und nicht Teil des Buddies. Insofern wird das Subject nicht verschlüsselt. Das finde ich immer sehr schön. Das habe ich schon ein paar Mal gesehen, wenn mir Leute dann PGP-verschlüsselte E-Mails schicken und den gesamten Text, was sie eigentlich sagen wollten, im Subject schreiben und dann noch mit so einem Klammer NT für No Text dahinter darauf aufmerksam machen, dass der Buddy leer sein wird. Also ich muss gar nicht erst auf diese E-Mail klicken, aber die Mail an sich, diese leere E-Mail ist halt verschlüsselt.
Also als SMS benutzt.
Na ja, und wer das nicht weiß, ist natürlich schon doof, weil wenn aus dem Subject schon hervorgeht, worum es sich in der Mail handelt, dann ist es natürlich doppelt interessant.
Genau, und im Hinblick auf Vorratsdatenspeicherung muss man auch festhalten, dass was die Vorratsdatenspeicherung jetzt im Wesentlichen im Sinn hat, nämlich den E-Mail-Verkehr hin und her, wer mit wem zu untersuchen, da hilft Verschlüsselung auch überhaupt nicht, weil das nicht verschlüsselt wird und sich auch nicht verschlüsseln lässt, weil dann die Information zur Weiterleitung der E-Mail einfach weg ist. Also eigentlich bedarf es eines Systems wie, was weiß ich, so wie Tor, ja, Tor, was halt vollkommen verschleiert, wer mit wem was kommuniziert, müsste man eigentlich ein vergleichbares Netz haben, was halt einfach auch E-Mails entsprechend verschleiert und voll verschlüsselt weiterleitet.
Wie man die dann wiederum allerdings gegen Spam härten möchte, das ist mir dann...
Genau, also das ist alles gar nicht so einfach und vielleicht sollte man doch wieder dazu übergehen und tote Briefkästen benutzen.
Oder sich anrufen.
Katzen rasieren und Botschaften rein rasieren. Jungs, ich glaube, wir haben es jetzt, oder? Ich glaube auch, wir haben es lang genug. Das war eine mega lange Sendung. Ich hoffe, da war jetzt was dabei für euch. Auf jeden Fall hat die Quantität hier gestimmt. Über die Qualität könnt ihr Aussagen treffen in den Kommentaren zum Blog-Eintrag zu diesem Podcast Chaos Radio Express 104. Haben wir noch ein letztes Wort von unseren Beteiligten? Nicht in dieser Sendung.
Macht eure eigenen E-Mail-Server.
Genau, macht eure eigenen E-Mail-Server, gebt kluge Kommentare ab und wir hören euch zu. Und dann machen wir jetzt hier die Laptops gleich alle zu. Ich sage Tschüss, danke Dirk, danke Daniel. Und auch ich sage Tschüss und wünsche euch noch eine gute Zeit. Bis zum nächsten Chaos Radio Express.